14 days to flatten a perv uh what i mean
by that is
in 14 days the resignation of governor
andrew cuomo will be official the man is
out and good riddance everybody is happy
literally everybody even the people who
pretended to be quomosexuals are
pretending like they don't like cuomo
now or i guess maybe they were
pretending to have liked him in the
first place but
it's more than just his resignation he
said he knew the writing was on the wall
democrats and republicans wanted him out
so he decided to resign because he was
facing impeachment
he's actually facing arrest and criminal
prosecution recently a sheriff came out
and said if these accusations you know
have weight
we will arrest and charge andrew cuomo
now that remains to be seen i mean maybe
he's resigning now because he's trying
to get out while he still can
because he could potentially be arrested
for some of these accusations and
they're pretty nasty accusations but i
tell you what the one thing that kind of
bums me out he's not resigning because
he murdered all those old people he's
resigning because of the accusations
from female staffers and stuff so at the
very least you know what it's a good
thing that he's gone so we'll definitely
get into that we got a bunch of other
stories to talk about the economy and uh
you know we'll just have a good hangout
because we're being joined by michaela
peterson
thank you so much for inviting me
absolutely do you want to introduce
yourself
i'm michaela peterson i have a podcast
i'm probably more well known for my all
meat lion diet
yes that i'm jordan peterson's daughter
well known for that as well
uh that's pretty good i have a youtube
channel instagram i'm really happy to be
here right horrified by
your biden eating a child cartoon you
have to give credit uh uh for that one
to george alex opolis
uh because we have joe biden for some
reason eating a child
and it's just it's just i think it's
inspired by junji ido the famous like
japanese manga horror novelist but it's
we've had one person who came in and was
just like this seems really you know
like conspiratorial and creepy and i'm
like it's a it's a gag like we have a
bunch of we've got snow white zombie
apocalypse as well like it's not it
doesn't mean anything it's just silly we
have like a beautiful aurora borealis
over there as well yeah that is out of
place
that is really out of place
oh you know we like we like horror we
have the other one with trump and rogan
we took that one down a little while ago
we rotated them yeah but uh yeah okay so
you know we'll talk about we have a lot
to talk about uh what's going on here
dude what's up duh
good to see you bro well you you seen me
yesterday
yeah it's just as good as it was
yesterday hey thanks for coming i'm so
glad i want to talk about diet man
because this is what you're doing this
is like the conversation i think we need
to have as a society and a species with
obesity running rampant and covid
you know attacking people with with
obesity it's like it seems like people
thirty thirty point two percent of
hospitalizations were uh due to obesity
says the cdc and you're on yikes
whatever you want i don't even know what
you call it but like a meat fast or
whatever it is i'll just clarify real
quick they said people who got covered
and were obese like 30 of those people
who were hospitalized with kovid were
obese i want to make sure i'm very clear
very sad i saw an article that said that
it was china had recalled a bunch of ice
cream because it the ice cream was
contaminated with covet it was like a
that's that exactly is that a joke no it
was an article it was like a newsweek
article or something crazy and well
we'll uh we'll get into it so live
oh yeah yeah i'm also here in the corner
i'm very excited to hear what uh mikayla
peterson has to say because i've tried
to go carnivore it's very challenging
but it sounds like i'm gonna have to try
it we'll see how we feel after today's
show but before we do that my friends we
gotta sponsor tonight we have the
amazing virtual shield head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com the link is in
the description below and you can stay
safe with 50 off for life now virtual
shield is a virtual private network you
download this little program you pop it
open you activate it and what this does
is it provides you with privacy and
anonymity as you're browsing the web
so if there is a government hacker a
government hacker or a private hacker or
just some nefarious individual trying to
break in and steal your data maybe it's
one of these digital tech companies
that's got all these all the spyware on
their websites or in their mobile apps
this can help protect you from those
prying eyes now here's why the way i
explain to people is
we don't expect someone to break into
our house we lock our doors we lock our
windows and i mean let's be real like
most people's windows you just like hit
with a rock it's going to open you know
break open but we put that lock on it
because we want to have that that level
of deterrence
that's what virtual shield is it's a
basic level of protection for you as
you're browsing the web and you should
definitely check it out by going to
surfing internetsafe.com you get it for
2.50 cents per month but they also say
you can enjoy 24 months of online
security from the world's easiest and
fastest vpn for only 59.88 that's
actually 77 off and you'll get 50 off
all add-ons and other great discounts on
their other plans and they're proud to
announce that this month all discounts
are guaranteed for life that means 50
off for as long as you are a customer my
friends virtual shield the first sponsor
of tim cast still a sponsor to this day
they rock they are helping support all
the work that we are doing here from
just one dude in the living room with
this new sponsor who is like hey we like
what you're doing we want to support it
to now a company with several a couple
dozen employees and growing more and
more so i'm eternally grateful to these
guys check them out at surfing
internetsafe.com and don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member and help
support our fierce and independent
journalism directly and also you'll get
access to our exclusive members only
podcasts we will have one up tonight of
course
and you'll get an advertisement free
experience that being said let's jump
into this first big story
it is the end of andrew cuomo
timcast.com reports cuomo quits andrew
cuomo resigns as new york governor over
harassment scandal now here's my
favorite thing about this right he's got
all these women i think 11 women now
have accused him of impropriety one of
them is actually a criminal complaint i
think there may be another criminal
complaint he could potentially get
arrested over this the funniest thing
was and this is what i'm really
fascinated by um
i guess interestingly because of
something your dad actually said
michaela
cuomo's cuomo said he never felt he
crossed the line with these women but he
didn't realize how far the line has
actually moved
so his argument is touching a woman's
face and shoulders and rubbing your
elbow and all that stuff is totally fun
and acceptable but now these women
actually coming out and saying you
crossed the line he's shocked by it now
he's resigning over it so there was an
interview
that
with vice that jordan peterson had where
he mentioned that men and women working
in the workplace has been a disaster
and i think what he meant by that was
things like this
i don't necessarily agree if i would use
words that that you know that strongly
but there is a good point to be made
that the line is definitely
not as easily seen perhaps and maybe
that's because people like cuomo are old
and disrespectful i don't know what do
you guys think
they used to smack each other in the
movies like in the 50s guy like what's
his name would backhand a woman and it
was like socially acceptable
crazy how things have changed
i feel it depends what you look like too
yeah i mean maybe if you look like cuomo
people are like don't touch my elbow
like i think that's a big part to play
is that what he got in trouble for was
it just like elbow touching or was it
something like more yeah there's
something more but you know if we say
too much youtube will probably if we
okay yeah
oh yeah oh yeah one i think one of the
accusations is legit like a criminal
offense
yeah and he might get arrested for it
but uh hey look it isn't until proven
guilty here's the issue that he admitted
it not the most egregious offense he's
denied that but most women like there's
a photo of him holding a woman's face
like he's literally got his hands on her
side of her head okay and then she
claimed he touched her inappropriately
and cuomo was like i never touched her
inappropriately and there's a photo of
him literally holding the woman's head
and i'm like she's like that's not
inappropriate that's really weird yeah i
don't know what year was it how old is
this guy was when he grew up it was like
a normal thing for dudes to walk up to
him and just grab their heads
and that was like a sign of endearment
or something
is that normal i don't think the head
grabbing thing was real i think like a
hand around the waist when you're
walking by or something if you're like
an old dude or like on the shoulder or
something or like maybe on the side of
the head like i can see that coming from
an old man who's just doesn't know what
things are like now but uh face grab
that's a little odd face grab like like
two hands yeah two hands
i think we talked about it on the show
before too and like we showed the photo
and she's got this look on her face
dear lord help me my face
yeah like oh man the other best part
about it is that when he was defending
himself a few days ago he plays this
video where he's like i do it to
everybody if you're white if you're
black if you're gay or straight a man or
a woman and he's showing videos of him
grabbing people's heads okay like
i feel like that's fair then he's like
it's just my thing i don't know
just because he does it to everybody
i don't think makes it no it doesn't
make it it doesn't make it makes it
worse oh it makes it worse okay i think
it makes it worse
i think it makes it better really
yeah i mean it's not good for him and
it's probably not a good social thing to
do as a person but like then it's you're
not special lady so wasn't his defense
um i'm italian because that seems i feel
like that's also i feel like that's also
a good excuse that's part of it that
could be that i'm italian i'm old and i
do it to everyone is that can we confirm
that that he said that it's not don't
blame me blame the attack blame the
italian and me
i know that he mentioned it i don't know
if it was actually his defense that i
was like what dude i know italians like
to talk with her kiss each other yeah
yeah but i get that yeah i totally get
that
but it's like
i don't know dude that might be a little
bit too much and if people are giving
you signs like as you're getting older
you need to be paying maybe you don't
care though i mean haven't you noticed
like the older you get the older you get
the less you care can you imagine what
happens when you hit like
that how old is he 64.
yeah he's over 60. i guess i guess he
said i'm an over 60 italian american
male
the boston globe says that is not a
defense for harassment
it's really not though okay
but to be fair things have definitely
changed the lines have moved like girls
can now
take you in for anything like if you put
i feel weird when people put their hand
on my waist i find that to be strange
lower back yeah like lower back like i
find that to be a little bit weird like
please don't do that to me i feel like
that's always made people feel a little
weird though i don't think that's i
don't think the line like
i can't well i'm not sure i think it
depends on how the guy looks
i think you might be right about that
too like if you've seen that cartoon
where it's like this really ugly guy and
she's like oh it's sexual harassment and
then the same thing happens with this
really good looking guy yeah oh hey
what's going on you know yeah go out for
dinner or whatever it's totally
different i don't know women are really
kind of strange and touchy now too
though so it might be like way different
especially for yeah people have gotten
touchier for sure
women have always been strange though
that's true hands on the waist is like
opportunity it's like a it's like an act
of opportunity for a guy from my
perspective it definitely is like you're
going you're crossing the line it feels
like
like you're this like wild beast and
i can't i can't condone that
it was how i was raised though so maybe
that's why i think that we we have this
uh the comments that's the comment
talking about yeah it's uh it's this
like suave looking guy with santa's
pockets like looking good susan and she
says oh you're so you're sweet yeah and
then the next one is like a chubby
portly guy and he says looking good
susan and she says hello human resources
the funny thing about this is mad
magazine made a similar comic a long
time ago it's a mad look at public it
was a mad look at love or something like
that i can remember i remember reading
when i was a kid and it shows two
beautiful looking people and they're
like kissing in public i think that's
what i've seen and then everyone's going
like oh
and the next panel was two fat people
doing it everyone's like all angry
there's there's something really
interesting about it though when you
mention like the hand on the back or
whatever like is that sexual
is it is it is the man walking with a
woman and like putting his hand on the
small of her back and like guiding her
forward is he doing that as some kind of
like
perverse or sexual action or says yes i
wouldn't say i don't know perverse but i
would say if like whenever that's been
done to me i've been like i get that
kind of like what's going on yeah it's
not like you know maybe upper back maybe
that's like kind of guiding but anything
like lower back i at least have the
bodily response of like okay what's
happening here and i think that's
because that's not often touched and i
think that's just the bottom line
putting your hands on someone's face to
me that's really weird like that's a
strange crossing if you put your hand on
60 year old italians though all the time
i don't know man i don't know cuomo
grabbing some ladies
i mean you can handshake is fine a high
five is cool yeah a hug if you both
like want to but that so there are
different ways that you can hug somebody
too like you don't usually you don't
usually hug a guy like full on up front
up close hug him like a triangle or
whatever whatever you want to do or on
one side but it's how do you hug like a
triangle you just like keep your lower
bodies apart oh you like lean your chest
oh yeah okay okay
we have we have the photo oh no it's
it's not like he's grabbing her head but
he's got his hands like under her
on her neck yeah and he's holding up
sorry but he's got this weird lip biting
thing going on at the same time yeah
that's the line
uncomfortable he looks really creepy
it's like in the woman's face she's like
wow man you know what bothers me about
this is that people are it feels like
people are piling on i don't like this
this behavior where one person comes out
and is like he he aggressed on me and
then and then two more and then three
more and then all of a sudden there's 11
people
and like i don't want to set a precedent
or or continue a precedent that it's
okay to pile on well why not i mean
if if these women are scared to speak up
because he's powerful he's cuomo and
then one woman finally says look what he
did and then another woman feels
comfortable now because she feels she
wouldn't be alone in this like someone
broke the barrier so that others could
come forward yeah and it comes out like
a a damn breaking right it's tricky
because sometimes you have that for
popularity right like oh it also
happened to me and then you get your
name in the news and so check me too
yeah kind of like that but but also i
think just as human beings especially if
they're not outspoken ones it's really
hard to be the first to do something and
so you could easily be being like well
maybe i'm the only one no one's gonna
believe me maybe it'll just go away type
of thing although if it's just like a
hand a head hold
so here's
something like it's not yet although
there's worse apparently yeah there is
something interesting here though that i
think
we need to consider when it comes to men
and women working in the same place
i don't think there will ever be a
circumstance where there could be true
social equality in the sense not like
workplace like uh career or or revenue
but just what you can or cannot say to a
man and woman will never be equal right
what two men can say to each other they
will never be allowed to say between a
man and woman what two women can say to
each other they can't say to men so one
example would be like the one i always
give is if uh two guys are like you know
coming into work one guy's in the
elevator and then the other guy walks in
and he goes oh damn that's a new suit
huh man you get that tailored you're
looking cut so you got a new haircut too
man punches him in the shoulder or pats
him on the shoulder or what if he says
like stop sexy
yeah i say that that's what it is yeah
yeah
so so but but i think the issue of
complimenting a guy's new tailored suit
like wow jim new suit looking killer
that is amazing you get that specially
done plus the haircut man it's working
really well that's a guy complimenting
being like you're looking sharp man
totally fine now imagine the woman walks
in wearing a dress whoa
did you get that dress tailored that is
looking sharp wow i love what you're
doing with this look
the sirens are going all
all of a sudden it's like whoa
does it depend okay i agree first of all
i agree and i think for the majority of
women it would be weird i think that
there are certain
types of personalities
that would be able to work with men i
don't think it's the average woman
though i'm kind of in agreement there i
think there's well like obviously men
and women can work together but there's
going to be some weird dynamic and
you're going to be like is this going to
be offensive or how is this going to be
taken what can i say exactly um i
personally i'll tell people this so i
have a team of people
everybody who works for me right now are
men
and i used to my best friend used to
work with me and she's a girl and that
was fine but we're like very similar
people pretty disagreeable and i could
tell her whatever and she's not offended
by anything
but i've noticed if i hire someone and
they're female
i have to be careful about how i talk to
them uh even giving criticism i like i i
feel like and maybe it's me but i feel
like i have to be a little bit nicer a
little bit more gentler whereas with a
dude i can be like can you just not do
this again and they're like yeah no
problem won't do it again but if it's
female i'm like okay you did like this a
little bit wrong here's how to do it a
little bit better overall you're doing a
great job everything's fine please don't
be upset this is no this is really
interesting i remember reading there was
a study about gender discrimination in
the workplace that found
women female bosses are equally as
likely to discriminate as a male boss
yeah maybe if not more but it was just
equal
i think it said something like it was
equal as likely like the issue wasn't um
the gender the gender of the boss the
issue was the behavior of the employees
and then there was like a tendency among
women like more agreeableness and things
like that which resulted in the more
like
executive stern types to behave in a
specific way that was
not related to to gender or you know
whatever yeah that doesn't surprise me
at all i think a lot of that's
personality yeah
and i i think you're completely right
because i am like you said i am the kind
of person who wants to know how i can
improve not just that i did something
wrong so please like give me positive
feedback and be like all right so you
did well with this did well with this
this needs work and this is fine so i
think that that management style of like
two a positive negative and positive
like the sandwich is very much like a
feminine thing and trying to protect you
yeah i think that's a good management
style anyway it just takes more effort
than just being like look i don't i like
you as a person it's not offensive it's
just can you fix this next time right
and then instead of having somebody soul
crushed
do you think that like behavior
transcends gender that
and that because i know jordan talks a
lot about this i mean i'm obsessed with
that guy what's up dude
like
that men and women have like intrinsic
you know behavioral patterns not that
every woman has it but that women are
more you know nurturing and mentally
more into things women are more to
people
but does that is that it's not always
the case obviously there are people that
that transcend that that dichotomy
and i wonder if you know especially with
the what we're the age of like a
thousand genders and and
heteronormativity and and what do you
call it post-modernism like maybe
there's something maybe maybe we're all
becoming like genderless
you know babies and test tubes
i don't think so i mean i think i think
society is changing in a way that
encourages certain behaviors and stuff
but
testosterone plays a role man and a lot
of things
i think people are getting sicker and
that's part of the problem interesting
like i think that if you're on i mean i
don't know what percentage of the
population is on some sort of like psych
med at the moment or on
yeah and since covet has gotten worse
and those things have like they make
people different than they are so i
think people like obviously people are
getting sick one in five people have an
autoimmune disorder people are gaining
weight like mad and i think that comes
with mental problems and i think that
screws up your behavior including
probably the more normal
like feminine and masculine behavior
it's interlinked i think i think people
who are living unhealthy lives are more
likely to have some kind of illness that
requires medication which then in turn
creates this cycle of
addiction and
endless ailment i suppose
i do want to i think we should we should
uh i want to loot back to this other
story we have because i think that will
lead us into a bigger conversation about
like diet and health and stuff that i
want to say for a little bit because we
have this story that uh it beautifully
jumps us into how critical race theory
is is uh i shouldn't say critical race
theory but critical gender theory
critical race theory and wokism is make
it it's it's manifesting in society so
as we're talking about like cuomo and
women and stuff and these dynamics we
have the story nick cannon calls having
children with one woman a eurocentric
concept the tv presenter has seven
children with four different women
so perhaps he's only saying that because
he's non-monogamous
what they say
cannon welcomed twins
zion mixolydian and zillionaire with
abby dela rosa on june 14th his son zen
whom he shares with model alyssa scott
was born nine days after zillion and
zion additionally canon welcomed
daughter powerful queen back in december
with brittany bell with whom he also
shares four-year-old son golden cannon
is also dead to ten-year-old twins son
moroccan and daughter monroe
with ex-wife mariah carey says people
magazine well i didn't know that about
him holy moly yeah so uh when pressed
about having multiple children with so
many women canon said monogamy was a
eurocentric concept just to classify
property just like the idea that a man
should have one woman we shouldn't have
anything i have no ownership over this
person if we really talking about how we
coexist and how we populate it's about
what exchange can we create together
those women and all women are the ones
that open themselves up to say i would
like to allow this man in my world and i
will birth this child so it ain't my
decision i'm just following suit this
this is amazing the i mean he's
basically absolving himself of some
responsibility when it comes to having
these kids in a way that we're probably
not used to
i hear from people all the time
the dude will say something like we're
pregnant like referring to him and his
significant other yeah but you hear that
a lot yeah i know but it's kind of
repulsive like no
we're pregnant [ __ ] you have you been
pregnant you're not pregnant
i guess but the point is like that's the
at least the guy is saying like this is
something we're doing together like i
guess this is him being like hey they
want to have kids don't look at me
you know yes yes i see where you're
coming from monroe is a great name for a
girl um that wasn't what you were
looking at for a comment but interesting
times right
i feel like though to be fair for nick
cannon like he probably he must have had
discussions with these women that was
like this is who i am and i'm this is
how your life is going to be do you want
to do this and they still were like yes
so i don't know do you think or was he
just like by the way you're nine months
pregnant there's two other people who
are also come on like hold on he had a
kid in december yeah he then now he's
have another kid like
they must know i guess yes right yeah
they must know because she would have
been visibly pregnant unless they must
know unless he hit i don't i don't have
no i i think you know what it may be is
that in the modern world of feminism
these women have the means take care of
themselves yeah so they're less
concerned about whether or not there's
going to be a dad who's going to be
paying for and supporting the family
the catholic church i see where they're
saying about the eurocentric thing is
because like the catholic church is big
on monogamy and i don't know if they
were doing it for control uh or if they
wanted the the man to stay with the
woman to raise the family um
but like when you look at the muslim
faith they would have a guy would have
like seven wives
yeah but in the muslim world the man is
still a part of the family like you have
more than one wife but it becomes you
take care of it right a big family and
you're there and taking care of them and
all the kids right am i crazy well
theoretically that's what we're told i
just want to point out people in asia
get married
this is the problem with this critical
race theory stuff it's just a lie an
excuse to to for whatever behavior
they're engaging in that they want an
excuse to engage in so sure if it is
like monogamy is the the traditional or
social norm and now you're trying to not
do that so you just blame eurocentric
you know yeah eurocentrism or whatever
it's like
asians got married and they're very
family oriented you know the kids how
long how long have they been getting
married for in asia yeah i don't know
the history but i do know that
you know um you just think about the
concept of arrange marriages for
instance that go back thousands of years
i think they would have concubines in
asia so they would they would have one
wife and then like seven concubines and
it'd be women that they just had sex
with and had kids with no i think i
think certainly people do that that was
an asian cultural thing and like the
mongols would have concubines they would
have lots of
they weren't that's the thing is they
would get around it by saying you know
she's just my side right but there are
asian cultures that are very family
oriented they were very like you know
they they had these these these ideas of
um
you know different clans would would
come together different families
essentially
what do you guys think about monogamy in
general like
is it the way of the future
i think uh two parents is scientifically
if you look at most of the data proven
to
help raise kids better i suppose or i
suppose it should be the standard and
kids who don't have two parents in the
house end up doing poorly more likely to
do drugs more like to go to jail so i
think that's important but ultimately
i think there's a lot of people we've
got to make sure we don't fall into the
trap of this is the way it's always been
so this is the way we must keep doing it
we need to make sure that we're
constantly looking at like what actually
helps and benefits society now we know
two parents does so it's a problem then
when you see like black lives matter say
that we want to you know what do they
say disrupt the nuclear family
we don't we don't want kids with single
parents you know that's the data shows
that's really bad for them
so i don't know if i i would say
monogamy is a path towards that
but
i don't know man we're we're a
perpetually libertarian society in a way
now we've got this weird
authoritarianism which is more
disruptive of tradition as opposed to
being pro-freedom
so i don't i don't know ultimately what
happens but i can say i think the
direction the critical race theorists
critical gender theorists want to go
would be more destructive whether you're
for or against monogamy
they would native americans i think and
don't they may not be the native
americans but there were tribes i think
where they would raise all the whole
tribe would raise all the kids because
the guys would have sex with all the
women none of the women knew who the
father was so they would like
collectively raise all the children
together that's interesting i never
heard that to me that almost sounds a
little bit like a communistic way to
raise children it's like when hillary
clinton was saying it takes a village to
raise a child that's a little bit
strange to me and ian you mentioned the
church and that's interesting to me as
well because the way i was raised we
were taught that um christ is the head
of the church and treated the church as
his wife so it was like a big it's
literally like a big family but it
wasn't like that communistic raising of
the kids it was like a structure for the
way that the family should be mom dad
kids and it was like really simple
really fundamental really basic and we
can see that that's a good way to raise
kids is to have both parents in the home
they need to be together it needs to be
structural i'm hugely in favor of
monogamy if possible yeah but i think
everything's just falling apart well
yeah that's true i think everything's
falling apart i've always wondered so
those studies on monogamy not to be like
the anti-monogamy person because i'm not
but the studies on monogamy showing
two-parent households lead to like more
success for your children
people who end up splitting up
also aren't as well generally speaking
right so like are all those studies
controlling for like iq and mental
illness and things because you could say
i mean if you're going to have two
people who are not doing well in the
same house but would be doing better
apart
i would argue that it's better to have
both parents happy than have them
arguing in the same house
yeah um but so i just i don't know how
the studies were done and then were
there studies before when monogamy
wasn't the main
thing i think
i would i would assume they account for
something like this but it is a good
point i doubt it all these scientific
studies that i've read like there's such
glaring flaws i wouldn't be surprised if
they didn't account for something well
iq i mean no one accounts for iq anymore
yeah anyway
yeah i mean it's a good point though if
like the mom is on drugs and the dad
isn't yeah then it's like yeah that kid
would do a lot better yeah um
although i guess you run into the risk
then of uh divorce courts favoring women
right there was a there was an old case
that uh i read about years and years ago
where a man divorced his wife because
she was doing drugs oh no and then when
they went to court the court sided with
the mom and even though he was like you
can't give my kids to this woman she is
doing drugs and then she ended up
killing them somehow geez holy [ __ ]
yeah it was some some negligence or
something she was drugged and you know
the young kids ended up dying somehow i
can't remember the exact story i mean
you probably google something yeah well
divorce court is a whole nother thing
right
oh yeah yeah you know you get the uh
mgtow got banned on reddit so you'll get
you'll get all those you know mgtow
really yeah yeah they got they got
banned reddit a few weeks ago so uh you
know when you mention all this stuff the
legitimate problem is i didn't know they
got banned on reddit that's intense yeah
yeah well the censorship it's uh they're
they're homogenizing their view of what
they want the culture to be so they're
excising portions one at a time you know
yeah the legality of marriage is very
weird because marriage the word means to
mix so like two people spending a lot of
time together mixing their energy or
essentially in a form of marriage
whether the law says it or not doesn't
really matter yeah so that's like a
common law marriage it's something like
seven years ago but same person oh in
canada it's a lot shorter i think i
thought it was like this is gonna be
wrong but it's two or three it may be if
you're living in the same household in
ontario anyway yeah
yeah that's pretty yeah it's pretty fast
and i'm pretty sure if you split up
after that if you've been living
together then you still have court to
deal with oh wow even though you're not
yeah what if you're just roommates
no no no you have to be in a
relationship like you have to do and
whatever yeah but what if they say that
you are it's iffy i would assume that
that's still okay i mean when you're
filling out taxes and things and you can
put yourself as common law so if you
started filling that in and then maybe
that might screw you out over in the
future but it's short it i think it's
three years dude so so i look at look
the the the monogamy and polyamory thing
and and
polygamy thing i guess polygamy is
people talking about marrying multiple
women i don't know about that but uh
we're seeing a lot of these memes now
where it's like one woman like five guys
like i don't know you've seen him on
reddit
when she's on the couch
oh no that's a different one i'm talking
a slightly different yeah
different one but uh we know that one
we're all familiar with that one there's
like there's memes of like it'll be like
four dudes on a couch and they all have
their arms around like the one one woman
and uh it's talking about like you know
polyamorous relationships and things
like that attractive people regardless
of whatever
there's there's a few things to say one
not all change is good not all change is
bad but i definitely think
this is just a sign of things falling
apart
like to have kids with a bunch of
different women and be like well you
know they wanted to do it it's like yeah
but
i'm i'm sure he's still going to be
there raising his kids we're seeing a
lot of kids in a lot of different places
and he's not going to be able to provide
the same kind of leadership that
somebody who is you know in a family
with kids will be
and more to the point i'm just saying
it's just another sign of i think we're
facing we're facing for a long time
cultural stagnation movies were reboots
comics everything it was just
regurgitated garbage lowest common
denominator and now it's cultural decay
it's just
the movies are getting worse have you
seen warrior the tv show no is it good
it's so good oh okay what is it
it's about that sorry to interject it's
about uh san francisco and the triads in
the eighteen hundreds
it's like a cowboy western right now
asian people it's epic warrior other
than that society's over but yeah yeah
warrior
electric dreams i've been talking about
because i just watched that i think it's
a couple years old i'm not sure old
dreams yeah it's philip k dick
like that's cool i like that they
adapted the book into you know our
stories into these episodes of the show
it's kind of like black mirror it's it's
pretty it's a project okay it's an
anthology i'm not saying there's nothing
good happening it's just like just
warrior there was a period where we made
new things you know we wrote christmas
music and then we played them over and
over again then it got to a point where
a few years ago i was like everything's
stagnant we're rebooting movies we're
remaking
comic books spider-man 12 you know just
keep doing it over and over and over
again the same thing instead of making
new things now we're at the point where
they're starting to regurgitate the same
content but in worse worse ways
like the movies you know get well go
broke as people often bring up when it
comes to video games movies
they'll try to redo ghostbusters
and this is where the regurgitation
becomes from stagnation to decay i see
we should call it us the second harvest
of the film industry and that comes from
the native americans when they would
have a like a famine they would eat the
seeds and then they would poop them out
and then sift through it and wash them
off and eat them again
we're going to jump to this story get
what go broke because this is a good
this is a good example we got the story
from yahoo washington examiner um subway
franchisees want to drop megan rapido's
new adam at olympic controversy i think
this is a really good example of
cultural and political decay
not only that it's a get go broke right
so they they the subway has that
commercial with megan rabino and she
kicks the sandwich at some guy and he
catches something like that i don't know
it's one of those ridicules yeah the
subway sandwich but then she kneels at
the olympics and that's a very overtly
political move and gesture which puts
you at odds with half the country if you
don't kneel nobody cares if you do kneel
you've made half the country angry so
now the subways so the subways the
subway franchisees are saying that
they're going to be losing money let me
read the story and then we'll we'll get
into it
uh from the examiner they say sub wife
subway keep doing it again you got this
samwise gamgee
subway franchisees are in discussions to
drop team usa soccer star megan rapinoe
from a new ad amid her national anthem
protest the 2020 olympic games in tokyo
rapido who signed with the company as a
spokeswoman this spring regularly pushes
her political views usually calls for
equal rights and an end to the gender
pay gap these views are getting in the
way of the company's reputation and
sales some of the store owners argued
during a discussion forum last month
at the event hosted by the north
american association of subway
franchisees franchisees discussed
removing rapido from a new ad where she
kicks a soccer ball at a person holding
a burrito citing complaints they have
received from their customers about her
quote
boycott subway until subway fires the
anti-american megan rapino the creep who
kneels for our beloved national anthem a
wisconsin store operator red from a note
a customer taped to the glass door of
his restaurant the ad should be pulled
and done with the franchise he
subsequently argued it gets tiring
apologizing the subway company doesn't
own any of its nearly 22 000 stores but
charges franchisees 4.5 percent of their
revenue to you for the use of its brand
and national advertising campaigns
these campaigns an arizona franchisee
argued at the forum should use the
revenue to advertise the product not
politics spending our money to make a
political statement is completely and
totally out of bounds
so here's what i see with this
it is pop culture for half the country
to do these things the politics are are
mostly meaningless like the the they
they often don't mean anything what is
what is what is kneeling in the olympics
what does it mean what is it doing what
is it representing you're not conveying
a strong idea it's just a general
protest move it's not advancing any
cause other than corporate politics i
suppose and signaling to half the
country that you agree with some kind of
view of the country or whatever very
much in line typically with critical
race applied principles things like the
1619 project which are are to me signs
of cultural and political decay in this
country then you can see how it's
affecting business they're losing money
now because of it so it's enterprise now
businesses are starting to hurt because
of the weird things people are doing i
think the country is is split apart in a
bunch of different ways i think
culturally this is the best we have to
offer like okay this is a person on tv
who cares about their politics now the
business are getting hurt by it this
just says to me that we've gone from
stagnation to decay the businesses lose
money i mean you can't do it get well go
broke we knew that something like that
would happen now they're complaining
about it what do we do do we reverse
course and say we're americans we love
america or do we keep propping up
celebrities who for pop culture points
virtue signal about how america's evil
or some other garbage
i think it's the fuel i think it's the
food i mean
dude i don't think you can like
garbage garbage out yeah you can't make
people change you have to change the the
environment that they exist within well
you can make people change but you it's
it's not like to go up to a person and
be like stop doing that
it's to be like here's the thing we're
doing that works maybe it'll work for
you you know what i mean
i think you have to start making
patriotism cool for young people like it
looks like a lot of these ideas travel
bottom up like if your parents are
telling you something you're just like
screw off right but if it comes slowly
from the bottom and the problem right
now is with elementary schools and what
they're teaching there it starts at the
bottom and it just ruins society on the
way up that's what i think
so then how do you change that
it's uh imagine you got a jenga tower
and at the very bottom they're chipping
away at those jungle blocks and
everything else is going to come
crashing down when they do this stuff
and we're seeing the ramifications of
that
so but but i think it's a little i think
it's it's i think the stag stagnation of
our culture is is a um
is an important point to bring up in
this context just that
at a certain point people started
resting on the laurels of their of their
ancestors
you know i guess it's like good times
make weak men as the saying goes right
so what happens when you have a horrible
barren wasteland of a country and in
order to survive you strive and work
hard and you're sweating and working
non-stop you create wealth and luxury
then your kids grow up knowing
wealth and luxury but the hard work that
as you tell them in the work they do by
the third generation it's like they say
you know wealth lasts three generations
so i don't it's almost like the the
fourth turning i suppose we're at this
point now where
yeah these kids haven't experienced any
hardship yeah they have no reason to
support the flag or the country or the
troops or anything they're just like
this country sucks it's evil i hate it
i'm mad and now from the bottom up the
kids are salty
and then what happens everything falls
from you know
yeah and then i think usually when i
don't know if
the world's been in a similar situation
but i think usually when a society falls
and there's this huge war then you have
that repeat again right when i was in i
was in serbia last year and they were
just in war
with you guys i believe
in the
90s sounds right yeah yeah
and there's yeah and um they were like
there's still bombed buildings there
and so everyone there when covid hit
they're like
yeah we just we were just in the 90s
we're not doing this like we're not
doing the same thing as everybody else
we're not shutting down
like everyone else and there were riots
and things because people still
remembered how it was wow because
they've experienced hardship like
everyone there someone was injured or
like they remember it and here it's been
decades yes since there was vietnam war
or some sort of war or something really
dramatic and now we have kovid which is
pretty dramatic for people it's wrecked
a lot of people's lives killed a lot of
people
and so there's we're in this like
turning point where are we going to end
up you know coming together or
is everything just going to crumble
forever how do you introducing this to
your kid
i teach this teacher that most people
are really stupid
right like she's in montessori daycare
and some kid went up to her the other
day and was like you shouldn't eat meat
you know because it comes from animals
and that's bad
and i was just like those people don't
know how to eat like lots of people
don't know how to eat and they like
their parents didn't teach them they
don't know how to eat like there are a
lot of stupid people they're gonna bug
you
she's like yeah okay
um yeah we've had some i have a funny
story actually so she came home and some
little boy came up to her and was
telling her she wasn't allowed to draw
and i was with my dad at dinner
and i was like okay you can ignore those
people just tell them to bug off i was
like just tell them the bug off cause
there are a lot of annoying people
they'll bug you you're allowed to draw
if you're allowed to draw
and my dad came in and was like just
sock him
and i was like that's fine that's what
he taught me when i was in kindergarten
was just like i never socked anybody in
kindergarten but like just sock the
biggest kid or if anyone bugs you sock
him so he's teaching my four-year-old to
punch so we're teaching and i was like
okay that's fine like you know she can
tell we're joking
maybe she's four and so it was literally
the next day she came back and she's
like i punched somebody and i was like
oh my god we have like this was supposed
to be a joke and now like you got into a
physical fight at school and you're four
um but it turns out the little boy came
over the same one that told her not to
draw and pushed her oh and she punched
him back and i was like okay in that
case good for you yeah self-defense yeah
i was worried your dad was trying to
radicalize children into violence you
know but i'm glad it was just
it was a joke but she took it seriously
yeah good for her did he ever beat up a
bully growing up my dad
i don't think so no he was pretty small
like he's tall now he's six too but he
was uh he skipped a grade so he was a
year younger than everybody so he was
the one who was bullied right and he was
super mouthy so he was really bullied if
i could do it all again if i was four
jack him in the face yeah yeah so no no
no violence violence no no no but what
do you think when a bully attacks a kid
is the kid justified in fighting back
self-defense yes 100 otherwise you're
also gonna get you're gonna get bullied
forever like i have friends and they
they go to a teacher or something they
do it that way and then you just get
picked on forever i got picked on a few
times and i
switched into like if you do that again
i'll break your nose because i know how
to break noses it was very dramatic but
it was like okay and that stops things
right away but if it's like oh no like
don't do that or go talk to an adult
you're just going to get tortured
throughout high school so yeah self
defense for sure i i mean if if you have
the there's this uh there's two really
great videos they're both from martial
artists giving advice and one guy this
great video where he's like the ultimate
technique to win any fight and
everyone's like crowding on all these
students want to hear from the martial
arts master of his ultimate technique
and then he's like this one move will
guarantee you will win any fight and
then he stands there and then as soon as
they say fight he turns around runs and
he's like he just runs away and then
everyone starts laughing and clapping
and he's like any fight you get out of
unscathed is a fight you've won
you know and he's less crude but it's
like the saying goes you know if you get
into a pissing contest you just get
covered in piss so you get into a fight
with somebody
you're gonna get hurt if you have the
opportunity not to to avoid it somehow
and that includes getting picked on all
the time you have to but if you're in a
position where someone's attacking you
you need to defend yourself i don't know
if i agree with that like people get
tortured throughout high school some
people are just like picked on and
picked on and picked on and their entire
social circle falls and they end up as
the outcast i think if you're in that
kind of situation you end up punching
someone who's picking on you i think
that's the way to go but i think we're
saying we're not necessarily disagreeing
if you're if you are defending yourself
from someone attacking you like you have
to defend yourself but even if it's
attacking with words
what do you mean well i mean picking on
i don't mean picking on physically i
mean like i went to an art school nobody
fought anybody there but there was a lot
of bullying
over social media or just in person or
behind
your back i don't know just i think like
a solid
just that's how i manage it like i'll
hit you if you keep doing this i love i
love that was it tyler the creator i
can't remember where he was like how is
cyber bullying a real thing like just
close your eyes
just like turn the screen off
you can't though not with social media
now i mean we're we're live
if i if i engaged with every nasty thing
someone said about me online i wouldn't
have a job i'd be too busy having to go
through i just ignore it all i just
they're turning it off that's fair but
high school yeah because then you'll go
into school on monday and then people if
you hear them whispering about yeah
as a girl no but i think it's a
different level as a girl i really do
like i don't think i think that men are
more likely to get into physical fights
and women are more likely to destroy
your life by forming little posses and
being like oh yeah this person slept
with that person even if you didn't like
it gets
mean and dark and can like destroy you
he's got to be above it i think you know
i always
think you haven't been a high school
girl i mean i haven't but here's what i
would explain to my friends right
there were people who would fart in
class and then turn blush red and
everyone start laughing and laughing at
them and pointing like eh you're far
they'd be like shut up no i didn't shut
up yeah yeah and then there were the
other people more like me who would hey
hey ian
and laugh and everybody like oh you're a
jerk i'm like i don't care i'd do
whatever i want you can't make fun
because i don't care about what you
think so if you go into school and
you're and you're worried about
everyone's thinking about you you're the
person who farts i think it's
embarrassed okay we're on the same page
then here because how i countered
bullying from women was not only doing
the not caring but also addressing it
being like don't talk [ __ ] about me
unless you want to fight like seriously
straight up so it wasn't
i think that's a similar page but like
shirking away from it and ignoring it
certainly didn't work with women i just
kind of feel like right now you know
i've dealt with this a lot of people
have dealt with this a lot of people get
so stressed
you know working in in in politics and
culture
being online it's it's endless
harassment i mean the death threats and
the creepy comments and just the the
insanity and i'm just like i don't care
dude you know sit in your little room
say whatever you want to say i just
don't care i'm gonna keep doing my thing
and you know what it's like i guess
eventually it could be a horde of
zombies piling up in front of you know
my car and then my car stops that's and
okay well i guess it happened but i see
all these lies all these all the all the
manipulation all the lies all the smears
i'm just like dude
i don't know you and i don't care what
you think and you are free to hate me
you know it's like i get i get
journalists being like so and so i made
this accusation about you and i'm like
so-and-so can call me whatever they want
they're allowed to believe whatever they
want to believe i don't care
did it go on for like 10 years or 15
years though what do you mean the the
abuse the bullying people broke it has
been a decade of me doing public
political not only i mean in person
because what i think what's happening
the reason why i was physically attacked
during occupy wall street
every school is a kid like i think a lot
of the kids that are i didn't grow up
with social media so it i didn't have
this this level of abuse where like it's
also happening when you're at home i
would go into school i'd get pushed
around a little bit and then i would
leave school and it'd be done and i i
just left school i was 14. you left
school i was like i'm out don't waste my
time i wonder if the social decay is
related to the kids growing up in this
environment yeah it's an interesting
social media
probably what did michael mallis say
that pr schools are one of the only
places that children will experience
violence right
yeah they're like little prisons like
we've yeah dude jordan's roaring an
example of the evolution of education
because he left that system and now he's
teaching online in a voluntary system
where people can come when they want
listen as long as they want and then
leave that's that's how i uh when i was
i've had the internet since i was a
little kid we had compuserve on dos so i
grew up with aol in early stages windows
3 from from dos shell we we had dos then
we had doshel we had windows 3.1 what
was the other windows the one we had the
original windows we had we had all of it
no no windows 95 i don't know it was the
one where it was just gray boxes and
you'd like before 3.1 yeah yeah and then
we had 3.1 then we had 95. i was on aol
the whole time we had aim cable internet
came out we got cable we're on instant
message the whole time i have been on
the internet and i was able to google
search websites i was able to talk with
other people and that allowed me to
experience the real world from adults
and not of all and not pretty at all but
hey look the internet's a nasty place
but then there's a big difference
between when you're a kid and you're in
school and the teachers treat you like
an other like you're not an adult you're
not to be talked to like an adult you're
not to be taught like an adult you
actually get raised by the children
around you so it's no no wonder that
millennials are basically permanent
children
i grew up with the internet where i was
there was adults on forums talking about
music and things like that that i was
into and game development and so
there'll be someone like hey here's how
you do x y and z and they wouldn't treat
me like a child because they didn't know
all they knew is someone said hey how do
you do the the parallax scrolling thing
i saw in that video game it's really
really cool and they say oh here's how
you do it here's the code and and then
i'm back awesome and then i go and do it
i think you're right and i think that
compounding that's being raised by other
children is the fact that you can
literally always run to a parent or an
adult when something goes wrong and i
really think that's a huge problem now
in the colleges you see these students
who are incapable of handling even the
slightest amount of like friction when
it comes to their world view and that
makes them intolerant and makes them
need safe spaces it's actually a really
big problem
it happens on twitter man people are
like he said that word let's get them
yeah what are you doing what authority
are you obsessed with also is that's the
biggest problem in your life like what
is because what can what do i do to get
that to be the biggest problem in my
life someone said this word on twitter
that's what i want my problems and life
to be what i'm saying man you were
saying before physical health if you
don't have physical health nothing else
matters as soon as you get sick but how
do you how do you how do you get people
to understand that without
making them sick
i don't um i think there are certain
ways you can talk about it i don't think
that you can really understand it until
you've been sick especially mentally ill
i think it's very difficult to
understand mentally ill people unless
you've been there so
i think i've done an alright job
describing some of the experiences i've
had but only because i'm out of it now
and i think a lot of people who are that
sick
don't get out of it so
i don't know how you i don't know how
you describe i i feel like your
solution kind of defies modern logic
yes so you're you're doing the carnivore
diet
and you just will you only eat lamb
yeah so i i reach there's the carnivore
diet which is all animal products and
that's the one that you see in the news
like eggs milk anything that comes from
an animal carnivore diet i reframed mine
as the lion diet
which is insane but i did that i did
that uh and that's
beef lamb or any type of room in an
animal so animals that have multiple
stomachs rumen oh really yeah
not any ungulate
what's that hoofed mammal
i feel like not any of them like horses
aren't yeah giraffes are goats yeah
giraffes are
yeah wow oh god i hope i'm right about
that i'm pretty sure giraffes are a room
in an animal
so so you'll eat like beef and beef and
lamb
yes elk sometimes
nothing else
and salt and water and i reintroduced
tea recently
but you do alcohol
yeah and that just discredits my entire
diet they're like okay you're only
eating oh yeah sure so you have an
autoimmune disorder but you can you can
drink alcohol i think but uh it's
distilled so like vodka and bourbon
there's nothing in it it's distilled
like three times
um
most people probably don't know what
distillation is but it removes all the
grain so i don't have any autoimmune
problems from alcohol because i would
imagine like fruit breaks down into
alcohol in your system i think and it's
probably really really good for your
yeah but there's a whole bunch of things
in fruit that aren't it's not just like
pure alcohol right like vodka yeah
pre-pure where do you get your vitamin c
from
so there's a tiny bit of vitamin c in
meat a tiny bit and it turns out if
you're not eating any carbs glucose and
vitamin c compete so if you don't have
glucose you don't use as much vitamin c
so you don't need as much vitamin c but
i've been doing this since december 2017
and the vitamins i was deficient in when
i had an autoimmune disorder have
recovered
since when what year december 2017. it's
been a while yeah here you urinate a lot
of the vitamin c out and maybe that's
because the glucose is preventing it
from being absorbed
i have no idea but they do compete yeah
so possibly if that's what happens so so
let's start from the beginning i guess
you were you were sick
i was i'll give you the like super
tight version of it
i was diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis in 37 joints when i was seven
i was put on two immune suppressants in
an anti-inflammatory medication
the immune suppressants i injected so
very serious immune suppressants when i
was in grade 6 i was diagnosed with
major depressive disorder or possibly
bipolar type 2 depending on the
physician and i was put on ssris
grade 8 i started to get chronically
fatigued so i was medicated with
adderall when i was 21 for idiopathic
hypersomnia so i used adderall just to
stay awake when i was 17 i had my hip
and ankle replaced from the arthritis
that wasn't kept in check properly with
the immune suppressants
yeah that's about it i was also
diagnosed with lyme disease eventually
um and
i think that's all of them yeah so how
did you how did you come to the
carnivore diet
um
oh i started getting this rash called
dermatitis herpetiformis which is an
itchy blistering rash and it's the skin
manifestation of celiac disease which is
the only autoimmune disorder associated
with gluten
so i figured okay maybe gluten maybe i
have celiac disease i got my genes
tested i have the gene for celiac
disease i was like i'll cut out gluten
just to see maybe that's causing my
arthritis and that kind of led me on
i must have read like 1500 1200 articles
on autoimmune disorders gluten link
possible dairy link and then i went back
to school for biomedical science to try
and research my disorder because at that
point i was so sick i thought it was
going to kill me my skin had stopped
healing from the rash i'd had two joints
replaced um my wrist felt like it was
going to need a replacement i couldn't
wake up like so i was like okay well
this is what i'm doing with my life
because i don't have a life so i started
researching and then i just decided to
look into diet to see if it had any
if it made any impact and at that time i
didn't think it would change anything
but i figured i'd rule it out and first
i went to paleo so like no grains no soy
no dairy no sugar only water no
processed foods
and then when i stopped taking ssris so
that worked that actually worked my
arthritis went away my fatigue went away
i got off of adderall and my depression
lifted and then when i went off of essos
arise i did that way too rapidly because
i didn't know they cause withdrawal
and that's when i ended up on the meat
diet because i got sensitive to light
and to sound and to heat and to touch
and to any amount of carb i was reacting
to everything so that's when i went down
to beef
and lamb and salt and water which was
like out of desperation because the
antidepressant withdrawal was so awful
when you first went on carnivore what
did you cut out
at that point i actually just went from
chicken and beef and fish and lettuce
and green leafy vegetables
olive oil
and apple cider vinegar so i literally
just dropped salad at that point because
i didn't know you could survive on only
meat so i was like well i need some
greens i react the least amount to the
salad so i kept the salad for a long
time and then eventually i was like i
can't live like this anymore because i
was having some autoimmune symptoms i
was not on any medication at that point
i was trying to get it under control and
i was like i'll just do
just beef because i know i don't react
to beef just for a very short period of
time so that i can reintroduce things
and monitor my symptoms and i was
keeping track of it on like excel
spreadsheets my symptoms and everything
and my symptoms went away when i went to
all beef
and
and then when i tried to reintroduce
they came back so i haven't been able to
reintroduce things i can have tea now
but that's like three years into the
diet and i introduced tea i didn't drink
for a long time because i was weird
alcohol was gonna be a problem obviously
did you go to a bunch of doctors and
they
no at that point honestly i'd been doing
paleo i when i went to the carnivore
diet i'd been dieting for two years
being more and more restrictive and a
year into dieting after i went off of my
ssris i'd been talking to immunologists
and and just nobody ever like my
rheumatologist didn't believe me like
nobody believed me i barely believed
myself so no at that point i was like
the medical community does not know how
to handle this do you know what breath
aryans are i do
yeah so uh do you know do you guys know
you guys know let's go
[Laughter]
off of light and air only good to them
and there was one woman this is a brutal
video where she claimed that she was a
breatharian she only just absorbed
sunlight and breathe to survive so they
were like okay we're gonna film you
for i think it was like five days
to see you know you
survive without eating food so you can
prove that you're not eating or drinking
and she agreed to do it and she was so
dead set on proving this by like day
three when her like heart levels were
through the roof she was she was she was
like getting sick she was dehydrated
they were like we have to stop now like
your your health is at serious risk
you're getting worse and so then she
said something like oh it's the air like
the air here is bad it's polluted we
have to go somewhere else and it didn't
change anything
so it's it's fascinating because you
hear stories like that as why people
probably don't believe you yeah well no
[ __ ] i wouldn't believe me either i
didn't even think no seriously like a
buzzfeed will come out with an article
and be like look at this person and i'll
be like yeah
i get it i get it i was like when i was
22 and people were like fix your diet
that'll fix your autoimmune disorder you
know eat healthier i was just like [ __ ]
you you don't know what i'm going
through you don't know how serious this
is like diet cannot have an impact like
that because my joints
disappeared right like it's not diet i
didn't think being gluten-free was a
thing i thought that was a fad i was
scoffing at organic stores i went
completely in the other direction like i
had no i was shocked i probably i i
probably walked around with my mouth
open for the first year after i found
out the diet impacted my health because
i really didn't think what i ain't
mattered at all so i get it did you see
like gummy bears and stuff when you were
a kid
sour patch candy yes yes holy [ __ ] sour
keys
i never had those high patch kids you've
never had a sour key have you had sour
patch candy yeah they're like they're
like worse more stale larger versions of
sour patch
dude sour patch kids oh my god so much
candy when i first went to the paleo
diet
that was my first food that i
reintroduced because i was like there's
no soy there's no dairy no one's
allergic to sugar
right it was like like a for a physical
reaction i was like sugar's not good but
no one's allergic to it like i want my
sour patch candy it did not go well i
just the vitamin c thing is what gets me
like i guess i could understand you know
they have uh uh like there's the keto
diet right
but it's keto isn't no carb it's just
low carb you get some carbs you have way
more variety than what i'm doing oh
absolutely but then there's um what is
it called gluconeogenesis
yeah where you the protein the protein
is converted into sugars for your brain
and stuff like that yeah so you still
have a stable blood sugar like my blood
sugar is usually at i don't know what
it's in
i don't know what it's in it's usually
at around 80 though which is pretty good
it's not like 50 is pretty low 80 is
pretty good 130 that's high and then
people go way up from there but mine's
at 80 stably so yeah gluconeogenesis
from protein yeah but the vitamin c
thing is what gets me
yeah yeah
yeah yeah well i don't think people
really know like um part of the reason
i'm talking about it is because
i would like the medical community to
take it seriously enough to do some case
studies to look into it because i've
seen it help a lot of people and it
sounds unbelievable
the the keto diet for i think it's it's
prescribed by doctors for people with
epilepsy since the 20s yeah it kind of
lost favor because anti-epileptics came
out and people stopped using the diet
because it was hard to adhere to but
yeah they've been using the keto diet
for a long time and technically this is
a keto diet technically if you wanted to
refer to it it's like a plant-free keto
diet but keto is way more fat than that
i was eating a lot of fat initially i
because i thought ketosis was part of
the reason it was helping so it was like
add on the fat and at that point i was
still having ssri withdrawal so i had a
lot of neurological symptoms and the fat
kind of i felt like i needed it uh for
about two years i was maybe eighty
percent of my calories were from fat so
i was in a i was yeah i was um
in like high level of ketogenesis but i
don't do that anymore we we've got a ton
of food here we've got snacks over there
with milk duds and skittles or whatever
no we don't actually wait we do have
skittles and sodas and you know like we
have these these meals sometimes when
guests come they'll like we have these
like easy prep meals but you actually
had like a little rack of lamb or
something oh yeah i full on yeah you
guys drove me
um
you guys drove me
to the grocery store yeah and i bought a
rack of lamb and then i cooked it yeah
it's legit in the oven yeah it tasted
really good too i ate part of it yeah
did you did you do like lifestyle
changes in addition to diet
not uh not initially so at first it was
just diet because i'm not like
i'm not one of those i mean i'm getting
more into it now but i was never one of
those lifestyle like biohacker people i
was really into neurotropics first i was
really into drugs and i was like how do
i drug myself better so i had this like
tylenol three at night gravel at night
adderall to keep me awake like i was on
like seven different drugs and i
actually drugged myself enough
that
i could think clearly enough that i
figured it out and got off of all the
drugs so it actually worked out for you
yeah but i started there then i went to
neurotropics then i went to diet um and
then i started like when i got a little
bit healthier i was like oh okay
managing my sleep actually does help me
uh saunas infrared saunas were a game
changer
no we don't have an infrastructure
infrared because they don't heat up
too much you can stay in there for a
long time and just sweat that helped me
so much when i was trying to reintroduce
food and having autoimmune reactions uh
infrared saunas absolutely absolutely
game changer and now i do like wim hof
breathing ice baths like i've gone full
swing i've got my aura ring but
initially
this yeah i don't know but it has three
little sensors to monitor your
heart rate oh yeah i want to get one of
those they're actually kind of cool yeah
they make you really neurotic about how
you sleep i got the watch which is not
the same but it like tracks steps it
tracks calories burned workout time and
movement per hour
what kind of watch is that it's the
galaxy something or other
android galaxy samsung yeah samsung yeah
yeah so i get um uh every day it gives
me like a little man like every hour if
i if i'm sitting down working on the
computer it tells you to stand like the
apple the apple watch does that right a
little man will appear and he'll like
start doing like deep knee bends or back
you do not get moving i don't just like
[ __ ] you i don't do deep knee bends but
i'll get up and i'll go walk around i'll
be like i shouldn't just be sitting here
non-stop staring at a screen so i'll go
outside i'll go check on the chickens
take five like a five minute break and
then go back and then it's like good job
and at the end of the day nice because i
because i skate every day so i'm getting
exercise uh i get i get the eight hours
of sleep well i don't think i don't
think i sleep for eight hours but i
sleep enough and i move enough that it
gives me little little hearts and then
it shows you your your days and you get
like a little it's a foot with like a
badge it's like you did it and if you
don't what if you don't do it yeah then
you don't get your little [ __ ] okay so
it's not that harsh
depending on how badly you can take
criticism yeah it should though i i
think we should actually make an app
where it's like you're a loser like a
little guy what are you doing with your
life my dad could pop up yeah yeah yeah
yeah yourself did you grow up this thing
you can find and carry it yeah did he
just like constantly like organize you
into this lifestyle your entire life not
not really i think one thing he did that
was super beneficial was he said as soon
as i got diagnosed with juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis when i was in grade
two i remember he sat me down and he
said you can never use your illness as
an excuse good for him wow yeah and it
was like
which is a serious thing to tell a kid
who has arthritis and 37 joints but it
was basically like this is gonna suck no
matter what but if you use it as an
excuse it's gonna suck more yeah and so
that was i think that was really
beneficial to me and i probably veered
in the direction of never using it as an
excuse when i probably should have spent
a couple days in bed but i don't have an
autoimmune disorder but let's let's
let's talk about this i think one of the
biggest problems we have right now as a
society is everyone using all of that as
an excuse
yeah i know it's exhausting right it's
it's i'm a victim for this reason that
reason or otherwise they're told that
though and part of the problem i have
with the medical community is when you
go in and you get diagnosed when i got
diagnosed
uh my mom because she's been she's like
the hippie of the family and she was
like can we just change diet and they're
just like hahaha they literally just
laughed um which is fair because dietary
changes are complicated for autoimmune
disorders
but
i don't know where i was going with that
what are we just talking about how
people are using their their their bad
lifestyles excuses for why they can't
succeed or yeah okay part of the problem
with medical yeah community is when
you're when you go in there you're
diagnosed they tell you
your only hope is us your only hope are
these medications and there's nothing
you can do about it and it's not your
fault and so it takes all the
responsibility away from yourself for
fixing it because you're like i can't
the authority figures that know what
they're doing they went to school told
me that i can't and i think if i had
just if they'd just been like
can't help good luck then i would be
like oh [ __ ] i have to figure this out
myself and i would have gone through all
these paths like diet exercise i just
would have looked um but i think yeah
the schooling system is doing the same
thing to people people are told you have
this mental illness
it's on you don't worry it's not your
fault like here's a medication or
or you're an outsider
so you deserve deserve some sort of
i don't know help for being an outsider
just yeah society right now is pathetic
did you see this uh this story we have
it from nbc team usa paintball player
kicked off of team after backlash over
controversial tick tock professional
paintball player uh players said jessica
mayolo's message which some perceived as
anti-vaccination and fat phobic doesn't
represent the larger paintball community
so what had happened was
this this woman
was like watching a news report i guess
and there was like an obese teenager in
the hospital with covet and then she
said your son doesn't need a covet shot
he needs a treadmill and so then like
some woman was like my dad invented
toaster strudel and i don't think he
would have she literally said that
wouldn't appreciate what you're saying
some parts of 2021 they're just great
great
paintball first of all paintball
olympics that's surprising i didn't know
that good
like paintballs in the olympics now and
they get kicked off the team for a tick
tock like but but
i will say um
one of the problems that we have is
first whether or not someone should or
shouldn't get some kind of medical
treatment is between them and their
doctors and you should seek the advice
from your doctor as i always say but
when it comes to obesity it is a a
worsening factor and the cdc website
even says it that yeah of the people who
are hospitalized 30.2 percent i believe
were obese
so we
this whole culture of fat you know don't
fat shame people i can
but i can say this don't be mean yeah
you don't have to be mean also yeah i
completely agree and when i so when i
went to university my eating like i was
surviving off of cinnamon toast crunch
and beer and ginger ale
and pizza sounds pretty good yo yeah i
was like freedom i don't have to eat my
mom's like bread full of seeds which was
also making but anyway um and i gained
weight i gained about 30 pounds in the
first year and a half
and
i
didn't really know what to do about it
because i was going to the gym and i was
like i thought that it was only a
a gym thing like i wasn't exercising
enough so i kind of understand where
people are coming from when they're like
i have extra weight
like what the [ __ ] do i do and so being
like maybe get on a treadmill it's super
condescending to people who probably
aren't super happy that they have weight
to lose and i think that goes back to
what you're eating and i think that's
just people need to be educated that
certain foods are not like you you eat
pizza you want to eat more pizza
there was a show where they like were
trying to help people lose weight and
they would they were it was a reality
show and so they set up cameras all over
this lady's house at the end of the day
they asked her like how many she was
saying things like it's not my fault i
have a bad metabolism i eat the same as
everybody else but i just keep gaining
weight so they set up cameras and films
throughout the day oh at the end of the
day they said how many calories do you
think you ate and she said i had you
know for breakfast i had this for for
and then for lunch and dinner i had
these things and it was for dinner was a
small salad so i would say you know
probably 1500 calories and they were
like you had 3 700 and whatever because
throughout the day she was snacking
always eating never stopping and she was
like oh i just had one one or two you
know pieces of candy and they were like
yeah but you do that every 15 minutes
and she thinks it doesn't matter but it
all piled up so people need to recognize
they got to eat better man i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna tell them to eat nothing
but lamb i don't know it's worked for
you but certainly like i think paleo is
fantastic oh paleo's great and that's
super implementable for most people like
it's still hard i went from standard
american diet eating everything eating
out most of the time japanese food
indian food you know out yes oh yes
and food man oh yeah that's been hard on
me butter chicken
chicken korma yeah do you put any spices
on the meat cumin or no i can't do it or
the autoimmune symptoms come back oh man
oh yes i think turmeric is really good
for you yeah i know i did yeah
indian food it was just
yeah it's just the best okay if i could
incorporate anything it'd be indian food
i mean you may have you may have cured
your ailments but is it really living
i've like i've been asked that yeah like
hands down nothing
uh tastes as good as being healthy feels
so for sure one of the things that
bothers me about the medical industry is
the way they phrase illness sometimes
how they say you have this thing and
it's like okay i don't have cancer they
didn't give me cancer and now i have it
finally i control it like your body is
producing cells too quickly there's a
reason for it it's not it's not a thing
that you that you get and that you you
need to eradicate well i i think
i think i i understand we're trying to
say like you have a uh
well i don't know i'm confused yeah
they'll say you have a cold now let's
destroy it and they'll go and they'll
try you're like no no no i don't have
something my body is acting a certain
way and there's a reason for it let's
locate the reason but you literally have
like the cold virus you might have a
virus in your body but the reason why
you're sick is not because that's there
it's because well it's because it's
overtaking your immune system for some
reason well so it starts attacking your
cells and then your body has an immune
response and the symptoms are your body
but you might also have the virus in
your body and not be sick because your
body's maintained it's killed it there's
there's actually we have tons of viruses
in our systems yeah yeah
yeah what that was just fun to witness
that's an interesting conversation
so important that we speak the right
word gee i would want to know that ian
what you would call it because it's true
that you have a bunch of viruses in your
body but at a certain point yes you're
correct a cold has overwhelmed your
immune system so how would you term it
as far as i'm concerned saying you have
a cold it's just like a super short hand
way of saying yeah you got this virus
and it's kind of overwhelmed you yeah
like are we going are we going to map
out like here's exactly what's happening
to your immune system now the leukocytes
in the in the and then the lymph nodes
are
yeah if you could like why does the
rhino virus produced so rapidly sugar
you know a lot of things feed the virus
sure
sugar's bad and the reason i don't i
don't think a doctor is going to pull
out the whole chart and be like now when
the virus enters the cell and the rna
action now what happens to your body and
i actually watched the video i think it
was kurtz cassagat where they explained
the immune system
it is insanely complicated the lymphatic
system it is not just white blood cells
no it is like crazy there's the blood
and then there's the lymph your body is
like 50 50 fluids you have this lymph in
your body
your mucus your snot it coats your feces
and it is the sewage system for your
body and if it gets clogged up or gets
too acidic your body can't get rid of
the waste and then it causes all sorts
of of chaos that's why people got to cut
back on sugar there you go and alcohol
well
alcohol is sugar turns into alcohol i
mean alcohol is bad
alcohol inhibits protein synthesis i'm
no fan that's why i don't drink you got
to
basically if you can treat the lymphatic
system i feel like because modern
medicine's obsessed with treating the
blood and and but if you can look look
at the lymphatic system the ph of the
lymphatic system they have those
massages i forget what's called
lymphatic massage lymph draining yeah or
drainage massages yeah something like
that
saunas saunas really help with just kind
of getting toxins out i think that's
part of the reason they helped when i
had autoimmune
reactions sweat it wasn't literally
sweating it out yeah but exercise would
work in that regard too yeah but you
really don't sweat the same way when you
get into sauna really yeah the infrared
saunas that don't heat you up too much
they like heat you up from the inside
out kind of so they don't if you look at
the thermometer it's not like 100
degrees or 110 or whatever it's like 80
but you're just pouring sweat you're
baking in the radiation that's you know
you're you're yeah
i i i we have a sauna and i've used it
and i'm like this is boring it's like
it's been a half an hour i'm barely
sweating i go outside for 10 minutes and
i skate and i'm just like my whole
clothes like i jumped in a pool well
then it's not like
something off with a sauna yeah maybe no
other other people go in and they'll
they'll sweat it's just like just
sitting there i just a lot of the heats
from like at the top it goes up to the
top and hangs out there you gotta go up
top and like that's where you put your
legs up on the seat no i'm not saying it
wasn't hot i'm just saying i sit there
for a long time and it's like takes too
long to actually get to the point where
i'm sweaty you gotta meditate whereas i
can just i can go on the trampoline for
a good 15 minutes do some flips and
stuff and
i'm just getting away it's funny that
it's actually hard to sit still isn't it
in society
oh yeah i can't sit still man yeah if
the camera was sitting on me the whole
time you see me fidgeting nonsense
nothing my shirt
i can't do it i used to have that but
then my dad fixed it
everyone's gonna hate me for saying that
but i had like you know uh when you put
your foot down you're just like up and
down and up and down and up and down
yeah i had that and like when i slept at
night i used to twitch around
and like act out my dreams punch things
he got bad yeah um and that all calmed
down everything calmed down how do we
get people to like
take responsibility for themselves
in every psychedelic drugs
that would help a lot i'm actually with
him yeah heroic dose of mushrooms yes
welcome to reality for a second and
they're they're they're legalizing them
all over the place
like colorado decriminalized
decriminalized right yeah not washington
but i think colorado did didn't they
yeah denver city denver oh okay
oregon yeah i think man they're so good
it's this is one
it's insane to me that these things were
ever illegal in the first place i know
somebody had a bad trip yeah
they're like that is a bad idea most
people should not go there some
president yeah yeah yeah maybe maybe it
was people were waking up
hard hard to control the population when
you got a bunch of people sitting there
staring at their hands going like
what's going on what am i yeah they the
berserk over here berserkers yeah
apparently they would wear bare skin
they were bear zerker and they would
take a bunch of mushrooms and go into
battle
i have heard of this okay what is this
where are they from like the scan in
scandinavia okay they were types of like
vikings or whatever yeah and they would
be tripping balls when they would go in
like they couldn't die and they would be
wearing no clothing or barely any
clothing apparently it helped them like
let go of fear
i mean there's a lot of really cool
mushrooms
yeah that's not the kind i don't know if
it was just mushrooms
i'm pretty sure that was something else
i thought it was some sort of
psychedelic
maybe
yeah it just doesn't seem like that's
what you want to do when you're on
shrooms yeah and let's go to war that
sounds horrible when would you introduce
them to a human what what age
so i took them the first
time just like i was fairly like two
grams or something when i was 18. so
uh adult mostly developed yeah i don't
know it's hard to say what like i think
psychedelic experiences can be insanely
beneficial especially
shrooms i really like
but i don't know if you'd want to screw
around with the brain too much like if i
think you pretty much want to keep a
brain as healthy as possible and i'm not
saying streams are unhealthy but i don't
know they do kind of like
you know they've got to be poisonous a
little bit on some level yeah so i don't
know later i think my most
like the best experiences i've had are
the older i've gotten
i don't know what about you what do you
think yeah yeah yeah
ian's right it was like 26.
they would uh some some scholars propose
that the berserkers and the berserker
gangs that's what's called berserker
king would consume uh hallucinogenic
mushrooms or massive amounts of alcohol
wow okay see alcohol i see that i could
see that yeah hallucinogenic mushrooms
going to war i don't know
there's like legends says that they when
they were in berserk mode they were
immune to stealing fire
but they could have just been like
really drunk yeah like i don't feel pain
i don't feel anything yeah totally
wasted police officers
i've heard so many
things about like jesus was tripping on
ergot with his friends and had all these
amazing epiphanies they saw him walking
on water i got though yeah doesn't just
like eventually make your limbs fall off
yeah it's pretty harsh back in the day
before lsd was synthesized synthesize it
from ergotamine but it wasn't they would
just eat the the fungus that grew on the
rock but didn't ergot give you like
hor like bad trips yeah it had had a bad
um physical side effects like
i was reading yeah
the salem witch trials they think it was
like ergot on the wheat yes and they
would eat it and they would be like
seeing like shadow figures
and then hang that woman oh that makes
sense yeah they didn't know they were
eating it yeah eating contaminated food
and then tripping and then like she
turned into a cat i saw i swear and it's
like no i didn't but you're a woman so
you have no say and the man's gonna you
know they're gonna hang you know
yikes
if it weren't for jesus
like if they work for jesus maybe it'll
work for everybody else yeah but you're
making an assumption i am making an
assumption but it makes and ergot
specifically because i've read a lot
about oh cheeses and mushrooms oh i
don't think anyone knows yeah you know
there's like there's a lot of really
really old paintings that have those
mushrooms that are technically more like
amanita muscaria mushrooms which doesn't
really make sense because that doesn't
yeah those are it's not kind of it's not
really it's not the same as psilocybin
at all i haven't taken them yet i i
tried amanita this summer
um in russia you can just buy it on
ozone which is the russian amazon
ozone love it amanita muscaria and it's
the red mushroom with the white dots the
one the super mario brothers basically
that makes them big yeah no no no it
gives you fortitude right no mario did
not eat a red mushroom oh actually later
on it did become right that's right i
think it was like orange scaria it gives
you like physical what did it what in
mario 3 they changed it okay oh no is it
mario 2
yeah i think mario 2 is when they made
the mushroom because originally it was
orange yeah orange and black or orange
and brown yeah but um did it give you
like fortitude enhancement i've heard
that people take it and go hiking and
stuff plus yeah it doesn't yeah they've
got to take a really small dose cause it
works on gaba so you can use it for
relaxation anxiety and sleep so if you
take like i took
five grams it's not the same as
psilocybin so the dosing is different
but like five to seven grams i was just
like
clonked out completely super relaxed um
and a few more like two two grams was
just relaxation but i wouldn't go hiking
or something on it because it works on
gaba so it's just relaxing but it was
nothing like
psilocybin i think if you take higher
doses you can get some visual
hallucinations if you stay awake but it
was pretty sedating what do you mean it
works on gaba what's that
same thing alcohol works on
neurotransmitter oh okay yeah so so
psilocybin well it doesn't work it's not
like a gaba drug benzodiazepines work on
gaba alcohol works on gaba amino mascara
works do they have similar feeling
effects
yeah it kind of felt like alcohol was a
little bit more like
had more of an anti-anxiety feeling like
sometimes if i drink i'll get like more
hyped up and with this it was like a
really heavy blanket almost i heard that
the from the bible they have the tree of
knowledge and the tree of of life and
that the tree of knowledge was the
psilocybin mushroom and then the tree of
health was the amenity the tree of life
was the amanita muscaria
there's a lot of theories about what
those things mean though yeah i've read
a lot of kooky conspiracy stuff about
like aliens and what the tree of life
and knowledge really meant
you know the spiraling serpents
represents dna and stuff like that i
think a lot of people just try and look
for hidden meanings and what may just be
a very simple thing it's like the tree
of knowledge is a book you know what i
mean
womp womp yeah
i'm sorry maybe i was thinking last
night how ancient like the egyptians
do you think that they were like going
into trances like psychedelic trances
and really seeing like shapes and
patterns bro
you know why dmt is so fascinating and
why there's a meme about joe rogan
asking people if they've ever tried dmt
and why now we have ian who asks people
if they've tried
you have
these stories about people having shared
experiences without communicating and
that's that to me is like potential
evidence
of something beyond their your mind oh
yeah right so there was one story i was
watching i think was on vice and they
were saying there was a guy
uh who had done dmt and he there was a
woman that he had met when and and
whenever he would trip he would see the
same same in the same place he would say
okay yeah the purple lady i have
comments on this and then this other guy
who took dmt said he met a purple lady
who was friends with you shane moss is
that who did who's that i'm on my
podcast we talked about this exactly
shane moss he did dmt a whole bunch of
times went to outer space met this
purple lady and then
he got his friend to do dmt
and while he was high he said hey the
people here know you oh yeah there's
this purple lady
she says she knows you and shane was
like sober and was like what the [ __ ]
and then did dmt like 300 more times
seriously seriously 300 times after that
but i got in touch with shane because i
did uh five and a half grams of
mushrooms
went to outer space and i saw a purple
goddess lady purple yeah and i started
talking about on instagram this person i
was like i've seen a goddess full on 100
sure there's a goddess out there i'm a
pretty level headed person even though
i'm on all meat diet yeah i was like
purple and i saw it on two different
drugs psilocybin high dose psilocybin
and aco dmt which is not dmt it's pretty
much it's like a chemical version of
psilocybin uh so i saw two different
drugs exactly the same hallucination i
was like what the [ __ ] is that so i
started talking about it on instagram
and someone got in touch and was like
shane moss he saw the purple lady and i
went to his profile and someone had
drawn her and it was exactly the same
thing i'd seen
yeah twice and i was i was just like
this is insane yeah and so he had the
lots of people see this purple lady and
they have the same experience is this
purple lady they're filled with a sense
of calm which is exactly what happened
to me i was in like a scary situation i
was worried about my dad he was really
sick
and she just like filled me with a sense
of calm and like things are gonna be
okay
that's the same report from like
thousands and thousands of people on
dmt's psilocybin aco dmt with this
purple lady you know it'll be funny it's
like your persp perception of her is
that she was a goddess but it turns out
it's just like the bus driver of the of
the the tripping world so everybody
who's going there just like sees the bus
driver and she's like it wasn't it was
kind of at the beginning of the trip too
yeah look at that i wonder if it's
purple because of ultraviolet light that
it's like a low frequency light that's
coming here's one of the things i was
thinking so we had uh you know michael
malus and we had alex jones they were
talking about a lot of the stuff that
the machine elves and things like this
and the interesting thing is there are
these stories where like people will all
trip and then explain the same
independently they'll be separated and
then it's what happened law we saw
similar things
i'm wondering like
could it be if we all have similar
source code you know
metaphor for like what makes our brains
work that when you're taking these
things what you're really just seeing is
your own code and of course we have
similar code because we're all people so
when people are like i saw this it's
like right when you look at the source
code of programs you'll see very similar
lines and sometimes many programs have
the exact same line of code that does a
certain function so everyone's seeing
that and then it's like wow we all saw
the same thing that must mean there's
something out there and maybe it's not
maybe we're just all humans and we all
share that you know what i mean i've
thought that too because there are a lot
of like if you do high-dose psychedelics
you see a lot of like snake-like things
and there are a lot of like dna
structures you see those pieces of art
that they literally look like dna so
it's like maybe we're not going to outer
space maybe we're going
in inner space and seeing things but
when you're in that trip and you see
those things like i saw that woman and
it was they were like six months apart
on two different drugs and i was like no
that was real
and i mean that's the kind of experience
you have and you can try and boil it
down to science but it seriously felt
like there's a purple lady out there you
know there there's like the great
question you know why what is all that
stuff and some people a lot of people
have faith they they they say i've
studied and i believe these things to be
true and i i know what i can expect and
i think it's it's it's so hard to know
i mean it's impossible to know that's
why it's called faith but when i hear
stories about you know dmt and stuff
that to me is like we gotta we gotta
pull that thread
yeah we gotta we gotta do there what
what's that experiment we were talking
about a while ago extended state dmt
yeah you're talking about the idea
um they're taking people and i think
it's in england and they're putting them
in laboratories and then keeping them on
like a dmt drip for i don't know how
long but days i think days at a time oh
cause it'll only how is that
that's past an ethics board i don't know
as far as i know yeah i don't know much
about it okay if you take people aren't
very aware of this because they're like
oh you take ayahuasca and that's like a
really intense drug but ayahuasca
doesn't last very long and when you go
to those retreats you take it multiple
times because it wears off taking
high-dose mushrooms like if you take
like six if you're me and you take like
five and a half grams or if you're
somebody bigger you take more that'll
give you a similar hallucinogenic
experience as something like dmt like i
couldn't see i went to outer space but
it lasts for like six hours
yeah i was wild i remember a lot when i
first heard of dmts when i was like 18
or whatever and someone they were
telling me the story about a guy who
claimed that after he took it he like
lived a full life yeah yeah because of
the time dilation yeah he was like it
was 40 40 years i had kids i had a wife
and they like they came to all
disoriented and confused like where am i
like
whoa yeah
like roy ricky yeah that game yeah do
you think he actually experienced
someone else's life or was it like uh
just
you know this is what imagination but is
that real that's probably real what i
was told uh by but at the time and this
is probably like this is one of the
first things i heard about it they said
when you die your brain you know the
your glands or whatever releases a high
dose of dmt and so then my other friend
was just like what if when you die you
get sent into an inner universe through
the dmt release into your brain and then
you live a full other life that's what
this is check it out check it out whoa
check it out hold on hold on so here you
are in this life right you're 70 years
old and you die in your sleep your brain
releases dmt which then like inception
sends you to another universe where time
time
on your bed is like slowed down and now
you live seven years but in that life
you die again dmt is releasing your
brain and you go to another deeper level
like inception yes and one day it's all
gonna snap back and
and then you're gonna go back to your
original life and that's the you're just
gonna wake up and scream no you're down
your sleep okay okay you die before you
wake up well you know like you die and
then the dmt gets released and then it
sends you to a new life well that's what
these extended state dmt experiments are
kind of looking for us they're trying to
mimic that state they're trying to keep
people there with i think it's like
low-dose dmt too i don't think they're
giving them the big the megadose i don't
know and then they want to see like
what's it like when you're in there is
it like
is it like that are you experiencing
other lifetimes is it
jesus extended like when i did the hydro
shrooms it felt like
years in there i had so many different
visions yeah i woke yeah it was crazy so
i can't imagine i can't believe that
they're allowed to do that because i
know even this guy shane he was like
yeah i did it 300 times i ended up in a
psych ward oh yeah yeah he talks about
it yeah he ended up in a psych ward and
he said that he kept going to visit
these aliens and this purple woman and
the purple woman was a girlfriend so got
to that and eventually the aliens were
saying
i want to come back to shane's world
like you keep coming here i want to come
back and he was like oh [ __ ] i can't
bring you back you guys are like you're
aliens i can't bring you back like no
one's believing me anyway because they
were like don't talk about us down there
and it was so real and he did it so many
times even though it's very short lasted
why not bring him back that he ended up
getting paranoid about it and ended up
in a psych ward why not just be alike
come on back i guess whatever he didn't
he was just like that's not gonna be
good for earth
yeah
can't bring you guys here you're aliens
shane shane it might be good shane bring
him back
they're coming anywhere you know here
here's here's the big the big issue
though right the dude
let's be real
he did a bunch of drugs a lot and yeah
and he ended up in a psych ward but
calling dmt a drug is a little
disingenuous because your body makes
your body has like endogenous opiates as
well and things it's still a drug i
guess defining the word drug is a little
confusing because sugar i would call it
a drug but they call it a food and it's
but they're just just a chemical
structure
and like but everything's like i mean if
you break everything down everything's
just like what what are those really
tiny things yeah that that's that's the
parts
fermions bosons
like what else spinners that's why
we don't need the cement yeah we don't
need the semantics you know what i mean
like if someone's trying to convey an
idea then we understand that idea if you
want to get specific you can get
specific but like well oh it's not a
drug because this but i don't do drugs
and they'll be sucking on a coca-cola
and i'm like dude yes you do you're
drinking sugar right now that's a drug
don't don't offend me if i use thc
caffeine is a psychoactive stimulant yes
and it's i'm talking about sugar which
they call a food it's a drug sugar super
like agitative and and addictive sugar's
not a drug according legally it's not a
drug but that's i'm just thinking about
the word semantics i understand what you
mean semantically when you say sugar's a
drug it's addictive
and it makes people erratic and things
like that and hyper but caffeine
literally impacts your brain blocking
receptors stimulating your muscles and
things like that is a psychoactive
stimulant
yeah yeah so people are like i don't do
drugs and they're smoking and drinking a
coke it's like you're doing a lot right
now actually yeah yeah geez i don't know
so dmt i think we should kind of
liberate that chemical psilocybin i'm
interested in but we don't know what
happens when you stay in those states
for extended periods of time like even
like mushrooms if you do one of those
high doses like it lasts it wears off
and you can't you can you can continue
doing it but you don't get the same kind
of experience right and i've done a lot
of hallucinogens
uh
and i've noticed if i space them closely
together the trips will get they'll
change and it'll get worse
and i think it's some sort of sign like
don't do these too frequently like be
careful with your body so now i space it
out because it affects the trip so i
think putting people into an extended
date state of a dmt high when it only
lasts a certain number of minutes is
super dangerous mm-hmm that means i'm
playing with some people
yeah but for that long like i don't know
some people what we would need to do
careful is we would need to go to the
exact same place where you or shane did
their trip with the purple lady take
someone
who doesn't speak english from a country
with totally different cultural norms
and see and then give them a similar
dose and see if they could describe
anything similar because if they did
that would be trippy i saw trolls i saw
trolls and purple lady on both the trips
that i saw the purple lady
what do the trolls look like
like short and
like kind of greenish and with like
pointy ears and like ugly super ugly so
do you think that a lot of like our
fairy tale figures and some of that
stuff from history that like the
brothers grimm wrote about was maybe the
result of some kind of drug trip because
it to me that seems to make sense i
don't know i feel like i have no idea i
mean it's possible it's like
psychedelics have been around and tons
of civilizations so yeah trolls yeah
maybe it's the trolls i saw purple lady
but the purple lady isn't like rampant
in disney or anything
not yet maleficent we got to write this
woman into a maleficent yes the purple
lady but she's bad yeah this was a good
purple lady interesting i think you
might be right lydia like a lot of pearl
jams music was induced by drugs a lot of
like religion comes from drugs too i
don't know about that seeing god and a
lot of that they just didn't write about
it the bible took all mention of drugs
out
yeah i think it's because it does make
you like question society and power
structures jesus himself questioned
society and power structure i don't
think that they had an issue with that i
think that if there is no mention of
drugs it's possible that that wasn't
really a thing now revelation people
really don't understand what's going on
there i don't know about that like
there's a lot going on crazy stuff dad
wants to write a book on revelation i
want him to for sure yeah yeah that's
coming that's coming great
what is going to be illustrated it's the
crux of revelation i can't get into it
yeah like the end of days oh yeah is
that it right the mark of the beast
yeah the seven you will not be able to
buy sell or trade unless you bear the
mark of the beast right right crazy
you guys are more educated about this
i
my knowledge is comes from a super chat
we got a few months ago where they
explained the mark of the beast it says
you can't buy seller trade and i didn't
believe it cause i was like nah that's
too specific oh no yeah no i did and
then i read it i pulled it up i was like
whoa that's our audience they're awesome
anyway how about we ask our audience by
going to super chat so if you haven't
already smash that like button become a
member at timcast.com for the exclusive
members only segment which will be
coming up after the show and uh we have
a first super chat which i want to read
so again smash that like button and
archangel 762 says please talk about the
update to the james younger case
absolute freaking tragedy we will
in the bonus segment because that one is
spicy for youtube yeah
all right
um
let's see attack fuji says marry me
michaela
that's nice
that's nice
axel thunderpaw says peterson's booked
say peterson's books saved me from my
lowest points and helped me develop
character i have nothing but respect for
the peterson family the struggles
they've endured and i just want to say
thank you
aw thanks man your mom's the unsung hero
yeah that's hard times i don't know
it seems like i'm trying to do the math
i'm like oh yeah she's the generator
here's a good one the generator
max stahl says habibis today is a good
day tim you often say that left
libertarianism can't scale up isn't
libertarianism inherently right-wing i
consider many many libertarians to be
moderate liberals in denial it is not
inherently right-wing big l
libertarianism like the libertarian
party is a more right-wing ideology and
closer to ancap but you can be
libertarian in that you don't adhere to
a strict authority you cooperate with
it's like this um on the political
compass you have left which is
cooperative markets and right which is
competitive markets so a left
libertarian would be like ian let's have
an agreement i'll mow the lawn and you
wash the dishes
no money exchanged at all it's really
easy to do when it's just me and ian but
you add 10 people and now it's like okay
who's doing what you're trying to manage
it okay how about mikayla you manage
what everyone's doing but everyone has
to agree to it there's no competition
there's no exchange of goods it's just
we all agree to work together it doesn't
scale up very well you get past 100
people and now no one knows who's doing
what
and people get confused and so they
invented money and then you get right
libertarianism where it's like okay i'll
just give you this universal trade
medium to exchange the labor that we're
all doing so that's why left libertarian
left libertarianism doesn't scale very
well
all right lisby says love you michaela
huge fan thanks for sneaking down to the
states
i didn't even have to sneak like people
don't know but you can't i think you
can't drive over the border
this is really stupid but you can't
drive over the border but you can fly
and people don't bug you because the
border is full of americans and they're
like we don't care
uh and you do there is getting back is
still a bit iffy but i've had covid so i
don't have to quarantine
thank you anyway oh
little tails farm says great news all 12
of our ayam samani eggs are fertile and
growing nicely in the incubator it means
tim will get some eggs in the future
when they begin to lay little tails farm
youtube channel that would be fantastic
so um we unfortunately lost some of the
eggs in the incubator because we had a
rot we i think we had two rotten eggs
and so
yeah and it was getting really bad and
so i
pulled a bunch of the eggs out i think i
think they were bad so we have i think
six now that are growing so that's so
cool
that's so cool did you see him he has a
flashlight yeah like the blood vessels
take a little flashlight i want to see
the eggs yeah and you can see them move
too they like really
oh yeah i want to see that yeah
yep
all right let's see where are we at
a lot of people are saying let's get the
tappan zee back now yes because cuomo is
out all right
bogdanoff says tim and team please get
louis rossman right to repair guy on
your show he said he has tried to
contact you multiple times but no
response
well that's funny because i tried
multiple times to contact him so it
sounds like we just need to communicate
a little better he did email me we're
going to make it happen he's busy he's
running
i totally get it
all right let's see tim rowe says
central new york here we wanted cuomo
gone for years never represented us in a
sticky situation most people north of
city are more right-wing but cities
control the state
yeah there you go
all right
malty says hello michaela what is your
dad's philosophical view on neutering
pets or having pets do you think they
have aspirations to have children like
us
i have never been asked that question
before that's a good question um that's
why i wanted to read it you know yeah
that's a that's a great question
do pets have aspirations like i don't
think they have aspirations like us
so i don't think he i don't think he
cares about that sorry does he like
having pets though
he really likes cats me too
but um and
cats specifically but then i was
allergic to cats and so is my mom so
kind of crushed that dream that's why he
has to pet one when he sees it yeah yeah
yeah that's not good any cat that's out
there none at home that's true
someone said rand paul was suspended
from youtube geez
yeah that video we put out i wouldn't be
surprised you saw it no it's like resist
they can't arrest us all oh well yeah
that's gonna yep
that's the way to go fast his shirt was
off and he was riding a stallion holding
a sword
amazing it's like the civil rights era
again but instead of getting dragged off
in handcuffs now they're just getting
banned yeah they're getting like a
spider
mike g says tim texas is turning blue
texas hold my beer the texas supreme
court voted to uphold arresting
democrats for leaving the state during
session nice try tim
hey look i'm not saying it's it's it's
blue now so obviously the supreme court
is saying arrest them all these
hollywood celebrities are moving in
texas and they're bringing their staff
with them may i make a point what else a
court in texas did recently with james
younger you guys should look that up if
you haven't
we'll be talking about that i know i'm
just saying
all right
um let's see
i don't know what this is pertaining to
but uh i'm going to read the question
anyway sloth leadfoot says michaela
recently planned a podcast with tim
dillon that hasn't been released he
keeps
canceling
this guy is he's hard to get a hold of
no he's not hard to get a hold of he's
not hard to get a hold of he's hard to
get a podcast with it was like day
before cancellations twice oh i was like
okay you know i i just found out he was
one of the biggest podcasts in the world
yeah like number four who tim
dylan yeah it's massive he's got to be
the most popular community in the states
right now
he just appeared out of nowhere
to me did you i didn't know it was like
two years ago i didn't i never heard his
name i hadn't
did you huge yeah like you went on a
rogue year
a bit ago or something yeah he's massive
though but yeah so there's no podcast it
will come when tim wants to come on
there you go so it goes fine castle says
i have an important question i want to
ask michaela peterson is the room clean
such a great guest love both your
podcasts
it's spotless in here
yeah spotless super organized
our kitchen wasn't
but that's because everyone's always
cooking and there's like zucchinis
everywhere
there's a lot of seeds we have we have
like 30 eggs right now
because people don't eat eggs apparently
i thought i hate eggs we're getting
we're getting now five eggs per day
soon to be six heck yeah thank you so
much to chickens
people chickens are good yeah but then
we got what do we do with all the
chickens eat them yeah but you can eat
them after like what is it like a year
it takes a while it takes a year you
don't have the like gmo chickens they
grow really fast
like if you're preparing for the end of
times
you want the monster chickens they're
like this big vanessa is a monster
chicken she's fat she's huge
she's the one she's so if you go out
into the
little grazing area
she runs full speed right up to you oh
and then she stands just like waiting
the other chick the other chickens are
scared how are you going to eat that
chicken
to be fair
the the cast of chicken city i don't
think will ever be eaten
yeah they're like so we're we're
building the new cool we're putting
cameras up and then we're going to have
chicken drama and we're going to have
like you know team margaret and team
vanessa oh my god yeah it gets intense
that sounds like fun
the rooster i mean he's just drama we
didn't know we had a rooster too
we thought they were all hens and then
one day the rooster started going
and we were like what is that
suggestion i thought it i thought it was
an alpha hen because sometimes a hand
will become like alpha and start yelling
and then people were like dude i think
you just got a misgendered you know
rooster that was assigned female at
birth it was actually male 1 oh jesus
was it is it pissed off now
i mean he's a chill dude but he got
brave he he he he attacked me a couple
weeks ago so he's pissed off he's no no
he's just like he's trying to be
misgendering
no you don't know he doesn't know what
we're saying okay but i was in there and
i was like collecting eggs and he like
jump kicked my leg and i turned around
and
i'm not gonna say i kicked him but i i
like slowly put my my boot and lifted
him up and just like give him a little
like push and then he went nuts and ran
away screaming and was freaking out
because like you can't let him uh attack
you in a certain like position over yeah
then they'll attack people that's what
happens in zelda when you hit a chicken
they run around like that too well so
like the issue is if he thinks that he's
on top of the pecking order with the
people someone might go in there and he
might run up and start pecking them and
you know so i have to be like you have
to be that on the top of the diamond
side yeah yeah with your chickens and
then yeah we had we had people over and
they hypnotized them
oh they did that you put them on the
ground and then draw a line and then
they do that
yeah he just goes like totally limp and
we just it's on the cast castle last
cast castle video the vlog channel that
we started oh there's a video this is a
real thing it's wild he just lays there
and then tim was like poking his legs
and he was just
why does that happen
i don't know i don't think she knew how
she just knew it worked yeah interesting
all right let's see we got it
i don't know i don't know what is this
uh leguma the gayen i think pronouncing
that right says i am a proud zil
quackson member of the zilquacs gender i
use zilks and squilks pronouns that
means i'm allowed to put my hand on
anyone's waist even though i'm hitting
ugly hideously ugly and resemble a
chimpanzee full of snakes
excellent super jackson snakes
that's very involved
chimpanzees that was snakes that's a lot
of work yeah good work
all right cameron terry says in
christianity marriage is one man and one
woman and through marriage you become
one flesh everything you do is together
and for god's kingdom christianity is
one of the largest faiths and so that
structure became prevalent
very interesting let's see it
part of it certainly
biological unification yeah ryan
berkabile says if you ever see pics of
keanu he looks like he's holding
everyone's lower back but in reality
when you zoom in his hand is always
hovering two inches away i did a video
on this yeah oh that's polite it ended
up getting like two million views and um
it's kind of sad
that
i get it it's polite but like i take i
take pictures of people we we put our
hands over our shoulders or people we
took pictures like that earlier i mean
yeah people are like hey you know it's
not like a sexual thing but keanu is
being smart well yeah but does anyone
care if keanu puts his like hand on your
can never be careful
or he's like
reeves yes okay so like but but think
about the threat of accusations from he
meets a fan he doesn't think that i've
heard he's super polite like he still
takes the subway and thanks like i bet
that you think that's because he's
concerned about accusations because i
would assume that he's just like uber
polite i don't i wouldn't say that he's
sitting there going like oh no what if
someone accuses me he's saying like oh
no what if i make someone mad by
touching them
so like politeness right
but it's a sign of we hear all these
stories where it's like you crossed the
line by you know you put your hand on
someone's shoulder and took a picture
with him so he's like his hand is
hovering
i'm like look what if he was at an event
and he's leaving and a young woman comes
up and she's like hey and she comes up
with him and she puts her arm on him and
he grabs her and turns out she's you
know 16 or something and then they're
like oh no look at this improper so he's
just like i'm not touching you you know
what i mean yeah yeah that's fair
i mean i i guess he's a he's a a
gentleman
kiana's great
old-fashioned yeah
all right let's see we got
grant thompson says in british columbia
it's six months living with a woman and
then you are in common-law marriage if
she is a roommate and she claims she is
dating you it will not be hard for her
to get enough proof tread carefully whoa
six
really wow i thought it was two years
well look that up yeah six months yeah
that seems that seems crazy i thought it
was two years maybe in bc or three years
in ontario or something let me see six
months
all right elizabeth uh carmela comedian
says hi tim and gang i watch you guys
every night with my son orion he's nine
and autistic although he doesn't
understand much of the content now i
pray you are all still around when he
has grown in this crazy world searching
for truth can you give him a shout out
orion his brains you rock brother yeah
what up orion thanks for watching the
show yeah what's up ryan keep it real be
nice to your mom too she's cool yeah
turk longwell says tim you're so
hyperbolic it's only politics we need to
smile be positive rejoice pray be kind
oh yeah there i can't say that one oh no
he uh he um
is making a point about electric dreams
where they say in the show kill all
others
i'm not gonna read it directly in the
line because you know youtube but then
he says fix climate fix schools it's you
should really see it you you electric
dreams there's a show called electric
dreams on amazon and the last episode is
about a politician who says kill all
others
and then when this guy is like what was
that like why are you advocating for
violence people are like why are you mad
are you another like what's your who
cares oh my god and so then everyone
around him is like he must be another
and it's like no i'm just saying we
don't we shouldn't say these things it's
dangerous and then eventually that
sounds stressful dude it's a it's a it
was a good episode i was impressed by it
okay cause i'm like it's literally the
the media saying fascist and alt-right
they just say alt-right and then if
you're like hey man you shouldn't accuse
me you're
that's the creepy game they play
electric dreams
sylveran soul says i'm in a poly
relationship and although mine is pretty
healthy i can confirm that most of the
poly relationships i've seen are toxic
and drama filled many pali people act
like they're somehow superior when
they're really just hedonistic children
interesting how is he not it no offense
to him but why is he not a hedonistic
child yeah i don't know give us the
follow-up
i want to know that too yeah
daniel welch says michaela how big of a
lurking monster do you think autoimmune
is we keep drifting further from an
evolutionary appropriate diet and once
triggered the immune system can attack
almost anything thank you for all your
hard work um
what was the first part of the question
uh how big of a lurking monster do you
think autoimmune well
huge i mean one in five people have a
diagnosis and it takes forever to get
diagnosed so i assume that it's more
than one in five people who actually
have one i think it's a huge problem i
think like the the health
state of north america is so
catastrophic if you go to other places
like you go to serbia or croatia people
there look like a different species from
certain areas in the states here so
yes a huge lurking monster that's why
i'm talking about it otherwise i talk
about fun things
like it alex yeah exactly like just
purple lady two hours purple yeah just
me being like all right this is [ __ ]
up aaron sondag says i love your show
and know you have cats unfortunately we
just had to put our cat casper down not
even 30 minutes ago
please send prayers that he is in a
better place and no longer in pain
sorry to hear it man very sorry that's
sad
spartan actual says as an outcast who
was bullied in school as soon as i stood
up to the biggest of them they left me
alone still was an outcast but no one
messed with me but yes if you can get
out of a fight then you
i still think you should just
just go after it it's simpler more
direct i want the trying to make them
laugh route but i still have harvard
resentment
i don't know if that'll ever
ever go away well more psychedelics dmt
maybe that's the answer microdosing do
you do microdosing yeah i tried
microdosing i didn't really like it i
microdosed for a while i was like any
honestly for shrooms anything below
three makes me kind of uncomfortable so
i do like massive doses or nothing at
all interesting all right trash panda
says a lion doesn't concern himself with
the opinions of sheep tywin lannister
that's some good writing
michelle b says hi tim wanted to shout
out jordan's deli in falling waters west
virginia not far from you they provide
employment to people with disabilities
check out facebook page and stop by and
try the best sandwiches in the west
virginia eastern panhandle oh that
sounds pretty good i'm going to go there
jordan's deli
definitely check that out maybe we'll do
a big order and get everybody in the
crew some lunch nice yeah we could do
that tomorrow that'd be fun
isaac desmero says glad you went
carnivore and feel better
thank you me too
all right
sock puppet joe says can you eat fish or
seafood
so after two and a half years i
reintroduced
fish and i get autoimmune symptoms from
farmed salmon but not from wild salmon
interesting for some reason so i can do
wild salmon but mostly i eat beef and
lamb those farm salmon live in their own
feces i think they eat different things
like even organic farmed salmon can be
fed organic soy now salmon should be
eating fish they're literally
carnivorous fish a lot of them are fed
soy so i don't know why
but i like i can do a taste test a blind
taste test and i'll get symptoms from
the what's this example of a symptom
um so generally it takes a little bit of
time but then my joints start hurting so
arthritis my skin breaks out
um i get my rash and mood dip
i'll get insomnia too i used to have
hypersomnia but now when i have
reactions it's insomnia so just
unpleasant i'm pretty unpleasant to be
around joints is the first one
uh no insomnia is the first one and then
joints and skin
all right quantum canines has started
the lion diet in march and lost 34
pounds in six weeks almost six months
carnivore now maintained weight
pre-diabetes reversed r.a symptoms
almost completely gone thank you
michaela love you yay
yay that makes me happy
that's cool nice
seth hauser says warheads were better if
you want something sour oh yeah
oh god no
like weren't those the hard ones yeah so
you can't chew them they're too sour
that is that is but poor judgment i
agree yeah sounds like you're right but
star patch kids are legit the best yes
that's what's up
kyle holland says vitamin c's lowest
limit tried is 10 grams and there is 15
grams in one pound of red meat
milligrams
oh he put 10g but maybe it's milligrams
yeah 10 milligrams yes okay there you go
that seems that i think that's what i've
read that's like an eight ounces like
one serving or something
seems to be enough to keep me alive and
without scurvy yeah
wow calvin fox says my wife is allergic
to corn-based and cane-based sugars
anything from the grass families but not
honey that's the weird thing so i can
eat a little bit of honey now i react
terribly i've got terrible like grass
allergies and things so i thought there
maybe it was there i couldn't believe it
because
it doesn't seem to make any sense but
yeah cane sugar is a huge problem do you
ever eat manuka honey
yeah
that's the stuff that's like heals
wounds and stuff
it does yeah they used it at the
hospital ian ordered all those types of
honey you saw oh oh you saw them nice
it just crystallizes yeah i know and the
crystallized version is better oh i
thought i like it like icing yeah it's
like sugar it crystallizes into like
sugar yeah that's so cool all right um
hayden says michaela is the absolute
best and her dry humor is my favorite
thanks for coming out tonight thank you
i'm really glad that you appreciate it i
tried doing dry humor on instagram and
people are like oh look what you just
said there's innuendos there i was like
that was the joke
dude brilliant people are brilliant
alexander l frett says europe was
polygamous before the middle eastern
religion called christianity spread to
the region islam allows many wives for
who has financial capacity but mostly
monogamous royalty had concubines in
asia not commoners interesting
hondo says tim can you and sheamus make
a cartoon of a super mustache man pillow
fighting zombie nazi we had to edit
because it won't let you say the short
version of communist in super chat
perhaps we had a really we had we had a
brainstorming session and we came up
with a really good idea for a bit i
can't say too much but it's like mocking
cuomo and it's like really dark you
probably wouldn't laugh at it you just
be sitting there disturbed but um i'd
laugh
i think yeah i think if you're into like
the pictures we have from george alex
opolis g prime85 check him out good
artist
if you think his art's funny then
this is funny but holy [ __ ] i'm gonna
have nightmares from that biden one
he's good man i'm a big fan of jinji edo
yeah the the the manga horror stuff it's
just super creepy and it's like
i had no
yeah i've been too insane at periods of
my life to like be okay with it like
that's a little too close did you watch
horror movies growing up constantly like
all i watched were horror movies until
realistically until my depression went
away and then i was like no more so you
were limited in what you could watch but
you also had like tv specifically tv
like we had two channels and they were
really fuzzy and simpsons was on and we
weren't allowed to watch tv but when i
got older like i had my computers i
watched tv shows do you think the craze
the dark movies drove you insane no
symptom straight up now yeah
all right jay dillilove says i'm a woman
30 year old carnivore for one year i was
30 before i lived my first day without
horrible pain michaela you saved my life
thank you
my god good good i'm so glad you're
feeling better that's why i talk about
this even when the media is like meh
like [ __ ] you so uh not a chance says my
dad the inventor of toaster strudel is a
joke from the movie mean girls
okay uh gretchen wieners drops it to try
and get out of trouble
so i i was pretty sure she was joking
when she said it was like i'm pretty
sure she's just being like you know okay
my dad inventor of toasters that's where
it came from okay yeah
that movie was good that's good i'm
going to use that
that was a good movie it was really good
yeah i got to watch it really good
christopher roth says hale lobster and
graphene i appreciate the whole peterson
family hope your father is doing okay
thanks man do you know much about
graphene
no it's a monoatomic layer of carbon
pure carbon oh graphene yeah okay i
thought about like graphing like a verb
of some sort calculus graphene okay why
would you why does that matter they're
gonna you can use it as a building
material it's like more electrically
conductive than copper uh you can use it
as a super capacitor for batteries it's
destructible like paper so we can build
like touch screen clothing with it
basically
yeah it's the 21st century steel it's
gonna
you can make clothing out of that yeah
it's to completely transform the planet
not here well we're still figuring out
how to synthesize it in mass amounts
cheaply but once they figure it out it's
going to revolutionize everything the
steel industry is going to have a lot of
resistance and the copper industry is
going to resist it which they kind of
are right now they're not talking about
it but
read an article 10 years ago and now he
wants to obsess it ever since
that's cool cool but i got him graphing
for christmas yeah tim hooked me up it's
a little old that's nice speaks my love
language
yeah thanks tim i was like i wonder if i
can but we also bought these graphene
batteries so here's here's an example of
what it can do uh you know those little
batteries you plug your phone into is
like external batteries yeah
they take a long time to charge so it's
like it could have two cell phone
chargers in it but it takes like 40
minutes yeah yeah they actually can run
graphene through it so the electrical
electrical charge goes in and evenly
charges everything so we actually have
graphene batteries that can fully charge
i think it's two and a half full cell
phone charges in 15 minutes
you plug it in in 15 minutes the
capacity of that can charge your phone
two and a half times
so why isn't it being used is it
expensive i mean there's i mean like it
is being used like you can literally go
on amazon and buy graphene batteries
it's still why isn't that the norm
because the copper industry is very
productive
and the copper wiring
it will undo copper wiring will it
really yeah
well once graphene on its own is brittle
but you can alloy it with stuff to be
honest i'm not a chemist but um i know
some
and uh
i think that's why we're not hearing
about it too much i'm obsessed with this
thing i talk about it as much as i can
all right let's see graphene that's
right look it up
as onewee rise says there is a huge dmt
inspired music festival august 27th at
the original woodstock in bethel new
york it's called mind church festival if
anyone is interested in dmt this is a
place to go interesting ooh to do it i
see where you're getting at okay
robin w says god is absolutely real i
had a near-death experience and you can
believe what you want but we will answer
to our creator our creator in due time
interesting was it a purple lady i'm
curious now i don't know if the purple
lady is god i felt it felt you know when
i had that trip it felt like a god you
know so i'm one of those people that's
like there's a lot of them out there
yeah i think god is like the cosmic
microwave background radiation have you
seen a radio telescope of it it's like
this web of energy in the universe i'll
show you a picture of it yeah i want to
see a picture fluxing through seemingly
everything
i don't know what i think god is
i'm not sure yet
maybe after dmt yeah
yes
absolutely blan blanugawa says check out
jbp's podcast with brian murrah rescue
the immortality key and professor carl
rock about the role of psych the role
psychedelics may have played in people's
going from paganism to religion would be
awesome guests too congrats on your
health michaela thank you yeah i think
most of us heard that story about like
you know primates taking mushrooms yeah
and like and then that's what spurred on
their intelligence yeah that theory yeah
interesting that's a pretty good
i like that theory yeah very good theory
it's a fun theory yeah it is a fun
theory
ryan sternberg says read alien
information theory psychedelic drug
technologies and the cosmic game by dr
andrew gallimore he plus rick strassman
running extended state experiments we
are at the frontier people ooh that's
cool andrew yeah yeah okay what was it
called uh it's called alien information
theory psychedelic drug technologies and
the cosmic game jesus that's not very
catchy i know all right
the author is andrew gallamore okay
thanks g-a-l that's cool and rick
strassman are doing the extended state
experiments on dnt dmt yeah i think he
wrote the spirit molecule right dmt
spirit molecule rick strassman possible
and they're the and he's the one doing
the extended state dmt absolutely that's
what that comment said he wrote this
spirit
that's the same guy really i think so or
maybe
laura says
you always say ignorant things about the
bible why don't you take a bible study
it's really disgusting having to listen
to you spout such bs dang uh what kind
of bible study because i don't like
sitting in a classroom why don't you
talk to sheamus
that i'm into we should do it on air we
should do like just pure deep deep i
love talking about religion it's fun me
too um you should definitely talk to
sheamus
yeah rick strassmann wrote dmt the
spirit molecule and is he the one doing
the extended dmt
yeah that thing extracted i think so
yeah
that would surprise me all right kevin
hauser says yo tim at all y'all are
awesome would you ask your guest for
thoughts on ephatic coupling how neurons
in the brain communicate wirelessly one
love and be transformed by the renewal
of your minds
ephatic coupling is fascinating because
basically the way neurons interact
electromagnetically is they send an
electromagnetic charge from one neuron
to the next and that's how they
communicate thoughts but there's other
ways called ephatic coupling where they
seem to communicate without any any
electricity they i don't know if they're
vibrating other neurons
elsewhere and that they've seen it
from what i've studied in one brain they
see emphatic coupling between a neuron
here and a neuron there that are far
away yeah yeah i've heard of this and
i'm wondering if you can do it across
the room because i don't see why not at
that point what are thoughts jesus i
have no idea like how the hell does that
work i don't know
oh man that is cool yeah got no idea
emphatic coupling you know when you like
call someone and it's busy i mean it
used to be the phones would be busy
they'd be calling you at the exact same
moment that you called them no i had a
weird experience where my friend called
my friend and i called one of them and i
i got into their phone call and they
couldn't hear me and i was listening
that's weird isn't that weird
so back when phones were mounted on
walls there were several instances where
i'd picked the phone up and it wouldn't
there'd be no dial tone and then i would
just be like hello and my friend was
like hello and i was like dude i was
about to go yeah yeah yeah you're like
dude i literally just called you yeah
it's too that's too common to be a
coincidence like it didn't even ring i
just grabbed the phone and it's
yeah yeah that used to happen to me all
the time too
interesting uh the good old days yeah
it's kind of fun yeah yeah
all right sonny james says don't feel
hopeful by any of these resignations
much like i didn't feel the gates
divorce would haul the face the faces of
the criminal syndicate to prison to me
cuomo or newsome's resignation means
nothing to derail the syndicate just
assembling semblance of accountability
imo
yeah yeah yeah maybe he'll go to jail
it's not gonna help anything yeah
hopefully
yeah but we'll see
all right
let's see we'll do a couple more here
what is this danine ss to the person who
lost their cat please google rainbow
bridge yes that's the first thing i
thought of oh that's where your pets go
all right let's see
waterproof towel says jinji ido sleeping
man that's the one
where time in the dreams extends gets to
the point the person spends a thousand
years in a dream and then some cool like
that black mirror episode we've got i've
we got a bunch of the jinji edo books
downstairs so good very recommend it yes
very disturbing i don't know
disturbing in my life yes i know life is
crazy enough oh man yeah i don't i don't
need anything that's her yeah i like it
that's why that biden thanksgiving don't
look at it
i can't stop stop stop
all right duloc says hello tim buying a
home in west virginia moving from
maryland in september i'm 24 years old
with a two-year-old and a fiance anyone
can do it go freedom yes gosh darn west
virginia man live in the mountains fight
the bears don't actually fight the bears
but punch the bears take out anyone
trying to bully you right
with your fingers and then rip their
throat open with your fingernails from
the inside that's not like how do you
stop a wolf or a bear
um like that if it's up on you in the
mouth right then you rip yeah
it depends on kind of bear if it's a
grizzly you i think grizzlies is what
you play dead right or is that a black
and one of them you can yell at you
black bear you make a whole bunch of
noise you have to fight them
yeah just intimidate them or make them
but if they attack you you have to fight
black bears if they attack you they're
gonna they're gonna kill you
grizzlies if you play dead they'll just
swat you around and they'll maybe leave
you alone swat dead oh geez
you protect your neck you crawl into a
ball and you just
you know go defensive or you could just
not live somewhere where there were
bears we got bears all over the place we
have foxes a fox is always lurking
around i love because he wants our
chickens because they're little though
they're not i mean they're they're
smaller than that dog but it's decently
big
but you could kick them right
i mean you're gonna get a solid kick
i'll tell you this you get bit by a fox
you're going to be in the hospital get
your rabies shot for the next few weeks
they're not really aggressive are they
foxes aren't they they run run away yeah
you don't want to get bit ladies and
gentlemen if you uh what's uh would you
kindly smash that like button and uh
hopefully that compels you all to do so
for those bioshock fans and uh follow us
at timcast irl you can follow me at tim
cast thanks for hanging out this has
been fun we're going to go to
timcast.com for the members only segment
for those that are interested in
checking it out and when you become a
member you're supporting our fierce
independent journalism so so please do
that is there anything you wanted to
shout out before we leave the live
portion of the show
i
don't
think so
i think actually if people are
interested i do want to mention an app
we're building an app i'm working on an
app with my dad called aim and it breaks
down your life into eight categories and
allows you to identify which parts
you're not happy with so like you know
health relationships work whatever
there's eight parts and then it allows
you to make a goal setting plan to fix
those areas of your life so it's about
building resilience aim it's gonna be
out next year i hope sweet awesome it's
awesome yeah thanks for coming michaela
thanks for having me that was fun yeah
i'll show you the cmbr after this is
where i think god is hey bye everyone
in crossland here
we're forgetting to announce ourselves
this show has been really trippy and a
lot of fun i didn't realize that
michaela was into all this stuff it's
gonna be a fun after show for sure you
guys shall join you guys can follow me
on twitter at sour patch liz as i
continue my goal to have more followers
and sour patch kids much as i love them
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see you all over at timcast.com
you